today
was the first day of the trial for derek
chaven in the
george floyd case and trial is being
delayed
because the judge wants to add another
murder charge basically
they want to add i think it's third
degree murder to uh shavin's
list of charges which is serious because
a lot of people think that second-degree
murder won't stick they overcharged him
basically you have to prove he wanted to
kill somebody
and that's gonna be very very difficult
to prove but let's be real
even with 3rd degree murder manslaughter
is going to be hard enough to prove as
it is
and a lot of people think chavin will
actually be acquitted now
it all comes down to politics if
politics plays a role in this
he could be convicted of all counts or
he could be found not guilty on all
counts because
they don't want the cop to go to jail
for this i think realistically there is
a good possibility of a manslaughter
charge sticking
but then you have the fact that the
minneapolis police department actually
trains their officers to
do exactly what chauvin did so by all
means criticize the department say you
don't like them for doing that
but can you blame the individual for
doing as he was trained to do that's
where things get sticky
in the end i don't i don't care
i don't think it matters what happens
they're gonna riot
so you know we'll talk about that we got
a couple other stories we got andrew
cuomo
facing impeachment uh because there's a
lot of things that guy did wrong
you know killing people and then
grabbing that woman's whole head and
like squeeze
i love this they said you know cuomo
cuomo gave out a statement saying i did
not inappropriately touch any woman
and there's a photo of him just grabbing
this woman's head it's like
bro you grabbed her whole head like i
don't know what
it's like it's inappropriate like if you
was touching her arm i'd be like well
you know he grabbed her hold
and then we have this i can't believe
i'm gonna say this burger king
tweeted women belong in the kitchen
that's that's them i didn't say that
that's not my quote
burger king tweeted that women belong
and burger king said this
in the kitchen straight quote so we'll
talk about all that
we are being joined today by classically
trained actor clifton duncan you want to
introduce yourself yes my name is
clifton duncan hello to all my new
friends out there i'm a
broadway veteran and one of the few
actors that people seem to want to
listen to
these days when i talk about politics
and current events how strange is that
that's the the most i've accomplished in
my career is creating a twitter account
and i'm
i'm that's a very dubious accomplishment
but i'm riding the wave right now
i like to say twitter is pointless but i
guess you know here you are i suppose
it puts you on the political stage in a
matter of speaking it's it's very
strange it's very strange you know
i i started because i had i had an
account before and i had an anonymous
account where i said this is what i
really think
and i was like you know my public
account i will just
i'll i'll use that for work but my
problem is that i just can't
shut my mouth and um
at a certain point especially when
things began to fall apart in 2020 um
i just you know i began to really freak
out and i said you know i i just have to
i have to say something someone has to
do and honestly it was um it was your
rant
last year it's one of the reasons that
i'm sitting here right now and you were
like you know i
i didn't knew that yeah well your censor
of it was was hilarious in the
in the clip like [ __ ] but um
you know but i said yes you know because
yeah i'm not going to get into it but
i've experienced in my life that when
people see something wrong
there's nobody they always say someone
should do something someone should say
something and then
you know but no one ever does and that
someone should be you so i you know i'm
messaging james lindsey he wrote back to
me and then i
i ended up meeting up with carrie smith
who she just happened to be driving from
texas to somewhere else
and we met up in atlanta and um
you know things kind of took off from
there and i just began just saying what
i what i really think and twitter for
all its uselessness and vitriol
uh it kind of caters to my strengths
which is like being being
a smart aleck and and being able to uh
and being able to write with a little
bit of flair
and um i i feel like there's actually
more and more people who are not
conservative but are about freedom and
free speech
and humor this politically homeless
space is getting bigger
yeah more people are coming into it you
especially yeah well you know it's it's
it's fascinating because you know i have
private conversations with people
um in my industry and and outside of it
in new york and in other places who say
yeah i just i i agree with everything
that you're saying but i just
i go and like you like i began to become
irritated because you know i do have
sympathy you know you you have things
that you want to protect in your life
you have a livelihood you have a family
that you want to provide for but at the
same time you know it's
i think i think 2020 has demonstrated
our our mass inability to do a really
good
and mature cost benefit analysis so
what's worse you losing your job right
now or
or you continuing to allow these things
to to perpetuate
and you know what kind of world what
will your children live in
you know a world where they can't say
what they what they really feel
where they have to keep lying about
things that we know are obviously true
um yeah you know this it's a 1984 world
where
you're looking at a picture of a blue
square
and you keep telling everyone it's a red
circle yeah
and then you know deep down you're like
i know that's not true but if i if i say
otherwise
that is that is an insane way to live
insane one of the most devastating lines
i've ever read in all of literature is
the
is the final line of 1984 where he says
he loved big brother
and i feel like
i shouldn't say this but i'm i'm well on
my way to cancellation anyway i might as
well say it
but but that's what i feel like because
now at least in my industry they're
you know you go and you're doing meet
and greet at the first day people say
well
you know say who you are and what your
role is and and what you're here for and
also share your pronouns
and i feel like if i if i do that now i
have no problem if someone wants to be
addressed in a certain way
but don't compel me to do that and i
feel like if i do do that
then in a way that's me saying well i
love big brother i'm going along with
with this
with this ideological bent that i don't
really understand another and then i
can't embrace
fully i have serious issues with that
and uh you can always culture jam
and say like my pronouns are alilah and
and then when they ask you to repeat it
be like you didn't ask anybody else to
repeat it
so i agree with you if someone you know
if somebody has particular pronouns i
don't care i'll you know i'll call you
i'll address you as you
you want to be addressed because i'm
seeking to communicate with you and
trying to build
a certain level of you know respect yeah
yeah but if someone asks of me it's like
oh if you want if
i you don't want you don't want to ask
me to play these games like to engage in
this stuff because i just
i just get weird with it well it's also
like you know is there
is there really any mystery as to what
pronouns i might go i'm 6'3 with broad
shoulders
and a baritone voice are you really
confused is either
no no tim huh that's a nice attempt but
it doesn't it doesn't quite fit not
quite
him did i get it that time that works
for me all right here there we go
him with a y it's like a warm glove it
fits perfectly it's hxm
oh okay him that's too much
let's uh uh we also got ian hey hey
everybody ian crosston what up
what up clifton you said hello to
everybody else but when you're talking
to me yeah
i see how i'm getting real with you
you're trying to you're trying to
ingratiate
communicate by the way before we came on
air this is hilarious
like we were talking about how i don't
know why but only leftists seem to
automatically see black people whenever
there's an ape or a gorilla or something
what the heck
all right so all right so let's let's
see
there's a there's a very good stuff
let's take it let's get the context real
quick there's a very very big
instagram model who wore the tim cast
irl shirt
she got like almost 11 she got 10.6
million followers
and this was just like one of the
coolest things ever so um
i don't know if i should shout her out
because i don't want to you know draw
undue political attention but she's a
very very big influencer and she has two
different posts so she's wearing the i
am a gorilla t-shirt
which is just meant to be a silly meme
about you know alex jones
it's not really political it doesn't
even reference jones it was just
something from the show that we thought
was funny that people seem to like
you should there should be no message
message conveyed other than
i am a gorilla and a picture of a
gorilla so she wore that and it was
really really awesome so we were talking
about it
but she did have one of the discolored
ones it's not the really awful this it's
just kind of weird looking
and then you you made a comment about
the left whenever they see stuff like
this they immediately think of black
people
and i was i was told this when we made
the i am a girl a shirt i thought it was
just a funny cartoon gorilla
and leftist actually said the shirt was
racist just
in and of itself being a gorilla and i
was like now that's racist yeah
like yeah just you so your point was if
you want to elaborate
it's like no i mean there's not a real
point to it it's just uh you know
you know i kind of point out absurdities
and things and it's just i
i i don't know what kind of person you
are
if when you see a primate you
automatically think of black people i
think you need
you need to raise help listen listen
like robin d'angelo says she's racist
yeah so i think a lot of people like us
who are just like
regular moderate liberal types by a lot
of people listen to the show
regular moderate conservative types
don't think of black people when they
see
you know cartoon gorillas or whatever
but it's no surprise then
that these racists on the left they do
think it
they literally tell us they're racist
yeah why would we doubt their own words
you know what i mean i think
oh just saying black and white is super
not if not necessarily race is just
ignorant because our skins aren't black
and white like you have like a
brownish hue i've got it they do that
like we're not i'm not white my skin is
not
this is why well even then that that
that in and of itself is just way too
broad i mean people say well
you know black people i'm like okay are
they nigerian are they trinidadian
you know are they are they are they
jamaican you know where are they from i
lived with
a couple of uh alvin ailey dancers in
new york city up in in harlem and
one of the girls was a a a
canadian immigrant with jamaican
ancestry i called her i called her
jamaican alien
but she had she had no accent so but
here in america
they would call her an african-american
i'm like that doesn't that doesn't make
sense
but i had an ex-girlfriend who is
nigerian who was raised here who could
legitimately be called an
african-american
you know that's why i never used that
term black american i worked with a guy
who was an immigrant from haiti
and he was here on a work visa not even
a citizen and we were talking about the
absurdities of like these forms that
make us fill out in these jobs
and he got really mad he was like they
keep calling me african-american i'm
from haiti
yeah and like it was serious because he
was proud of his country and like it
meant something to him
but they kept calling him first of all
he wasn't from africa and he wasn't from
america
yeah but like that was stripped away for
this for the sake of political
correctness that's what they do
i won't put white or caucasian on forms
i'll put other because i'm not white
and i'm not from the caucasus well
you're allowed to do that now yeah yeah
yeah like the caucasus region like all
from georgia to europe or something from
ohio all right all right let's uh we'll
let's get into the first story don't
forget we got cyber let's press
i'm in the corner i'm pushing the button
it's gonna be a great conversation very
long intro but uh before we get started
go to timcast.com and become a member
because we have just like we are
building this massive library
of exclusive members-only content i love
it about a whole bunch of crazy things
with a whole bunch of crazy awesome
people we got james o'keefe we got
sidney powell we got blair white we got
matt brainard
we had uh ben stewart in the last
segment talking about
alien civilizations maybe already dead
and dmt as some kind of path towards
another reality
if you're into that all kind of all that
kind of weird stuff otherwise we got
jack murphy saying progressives can't be
alphas
immediately i know many progressives are
going to be like i challenge that
assertion and uh you should listen to it
because it's actually interesting debate
i totally argued with jack on that point
because i just i disagree
tmcs.com become a member don't forget to
like share subscribe
let's get this first story let's get to
the big news ladies and gentlemen star
tribune reports
derek chavin trial court adjourned for
the day jury selection expected to begin
to uh tuesday unless appeals court
intervenes they say motions were
reviewed
during a short one-hour session in the
afternoon case resumes thursday
they say jury selection was delayed for
at least a day in the murder case
against javin
uh charged with killing george floyd
hennepin county district attorney judge
peter cahill said he wants to hear from
the state court of appeals
about the prosecution's desire to revive
a third-degree murder charge to the
counts
of second-degree murder and manslaughter
in floyd's death last may
which was captured on uh captured by on
a bystander cell phone and broadcast
around the world cahill who threw out
the disputed count last fall
said the prospective jurors home for the
day ahead of bringing them
oh he sent the progressive jurors home
of the day ahead of bringing them back
on thursday
is where we're at so far and outside of
this news about the delay we also have
they've set up barricades already 2 000
national guard being called in this is
always the craziest thing i'm like when
you know we're putting these videos
together trying to figure out what
the right title should be it's like do
we mention 2000 national guard called
into minneapolis because
they're scared people are going to go
crazy or do we just give you like the
straight facts and i was like let's just
you know let's avoid the like the ah
you know national guard's coming to get
you but i think it's fair to say
no matter what happens i think we'll see
riots you know i don't know i don't know
what you think
it's uh it's it's not going to end well
i mean there was a
i wish i remembered his name but there
was a guy who wrote a piece on medium
um way way with the around the time that
all this stuff was was going on and he
mentioned
you know it's it's a part of um the
mpd's code like they're allowed
to to use the the knee on the neck or
something like that
and in terms of restraint and uh i mean
his his whole argument was that
it's likely that chauvin is not going to
be convicted of first-degree murder i
just don't think these charges are going
to stick i think they're
second second second degree they're
trying to add third so i mean i just i
don't know how these charges will stick
but it's also
i mean this is a huge sticking point for
me because it's yet another in this
litany of stories that involve law
enforcement and a black person
uh being being killed that um
that are completely distorted by by the
press and
you you take this string of incidents or
you or you create this string of
incidents you know
you don't look at them on an individual
basis you know for me the eric garner
case
that was more of a gray area but then
you have like the walter scott case
where he got shot in the back and it's a
clear-cut case of of murder i think i
think that cop is actually serving
uh 20 years old was that the one where
the guy was running away he was running
away
just pulled it and bam and shot right
like that kind of stuff you're like you
know
i think i think the philando castile um
i'm shooting was also a bad shoot but
there's but
that was the that was where he had he
legally owned a gun oh right right right
right
and the cop panicked and shot him anyway
that made me angry because i was like
the nra should have been out here in two
seconds
right see and here's the thing on top of
that because there are there are many
channels on youtube
that upload nothing but uh um
police body cam and dash cam footage so
you can i mean i've seen hour i've seen
a lot of people get shot
but you can see hours and hours of what
police have to deal with
all the time and when you and when you
begin to see for
instance how a a routine traffic stop
that can be
uh friendly you know pleasant can turn
deadly
like that you know or you see uh
i mean the idea of sending social
workers to handle you know for instance
like the the uh capital insurrection you
know well i mean
it's just because you know when when you
see enough videos of like a six
foot five you know dude who's in some
kind of psychosis or he's on drugs or
something and
you know they try tasers they don't work
they try bean bag grounds they don't
work
they try i mean people they're emptying
their magazines into this person and
they still don't
you know what i mean it's just there's
so many more layers and there's so many
more things that you that you have to
consider that people just don't consider
when dealing with the police you know
what i mean take any one of these people
to a firing range
and then give them a handgun and watch
them completely change their opinions on
all of this stuff yeah
so i i recently was talking to some
friends and explaining them
the first the first time i ever went to
a shooting range it was during the
ferguson riots
i mentioned this so you know fans of the
show probably are familiar with the
story
they said the first thing was have you
ever fired a gun before if you haven't
we don't want you to go in there without
without someone to train you and give
you the basics
and so i said i hadn't but the guy i was
with
was like this hardcore war journalist
who's fired full auto
you know aks in the philippines and
other crazy countries
so he was like don't worry we'll teach
him how to fire a glock no problem
and my aim was actually my my
my aim was awful but i was consistent i
aimed for the chest and the target at
seven yards and i hit him in the groin
every time
but that's true story true story uh i
was like i was very aware of how i was
holding my body
and i could i could repeat that same
position but i was just shooting low
every time and they told me i was
probably pulling my hand down when i was
pulling the trigger
and they tried giving these pointers
what they told me was
the average person that they give a
handgun to can't hit the target at seven
yards
and believe it or not the other people
who are with us they couldn't hit this
thing i was i was amazed by like how bad
everyone's accuracy was now you imagine
you're what 20 yards away
the mythbusters did this thing where
they're like a person with a knife can
close
21 yards before the cop can get his gun
out so
the average person in a panic situation
a cop even with certification of some
sort
it's a high intensity moment he's
freaking out he's adrenaline rushing
and he goes for his gun and the guys
already closed the gap yeah
and if the guy's further away than that
he's got to be pretty good proficient
with his weapon
people don't realize man there is a
reporter who did uh who
you can find this video on youtube um
who was very much you know he was on
that narrative of like you know
you know anti-police and and all this
stuff and and he went and under the
and underwent the training and that
exact scenario you know someone and
there's again there's videos online that
you can find
of people with a knife and you know they
you know they might be across the room
or something like that and the officer
will get stabbed
several times before his partner is able
to to draw and take the guy down i'm
like
there's there's but this reporter was
like oh his mind totally changed because
he saw just how dangerous somebody can
be with a knife i mean
there was a shooting recently was it in
philadelphia where the guy had the knife
and people were like
he shouldn't have been shot i'm like
dude you just
he was on he was he was having some kind
of of of
mental i don't know if the politically
correct term is psychosis
or another episode episode let's let's
go with that and um
andy had a knife and when you've when
you've seen hours and hours of this
stuff and you see how it turns out
you know it it it's one thing if you
have an issue
with police using lethal force you know
i could actually respect that position
if you have an ethical problem with it
i'm just glad you're not a cop but if
you're trying to say well they should
never ever in under any circumstances
use i'm like dude sorry man that's just
not how life works it's not how life
works you are divorced from reality
i cannot ask in good conscience a cop to
go out there
knowing there are risks and i don't mean
all the time it's not you know i'm i'm
sure
they're they can be on edge in many
circumstances it's not like every day
they go out there
you know on the verge of dying but it is
a lottery ticket
where if you get those numbers right you
get a bullet and so i'm not going to ask
someone to buy that ticket
unless i give them the opportunity to
protect themselves in the event the
ticket comes due you know what i mean
yeah
so i see i see these cops who go out
there and i think we need police reform
i think we've got issues with police
accountability i've experienced this in
chicago always be better
absolutely and at the same time we just
had this video go viral where a woman
i guess the story was a woman asked
these cops to come in and protect her
as she was going into her home because
she was worried about an ax who was
armed and so the cops are like
he has a weapon let us know where the
weapon is and there it seems like
they're with her to practice woman
dude barges in the door and start
shooting like crazy this is a reality
man
when when you have to deal with the like
the violence
and the anger and so here's what ends up
happening is
we're asking cops to end the situation
but we're also asking them to
essentially throw themselves in the
sacrificial dagger
in the event that something goes wrong
so you have
i think the the george floyd thing was a
very very tragic case with a whole lot
of problems
and i do think that uh chauvin bears
some responsibility for this that's why
i said manslaughter may actually be
an actual outcome and the reason for it
he he remained on the neck three minutes
after floyd
was unresponsive and so maybe you argue
that the training says that's what
you're supposed to do because it allows
them to breathe
maybe your argument is he should have
set him up and then provided rendered
eight or something
the challenge is you know so like i said
they might actually say manslaughter
like
you know you could have done something
you were the one who restrained him and
the restraint was part of the
you know his reason for death but you
have many circumstances where
well let me start by saying this you
have many circumstances where cop cop
screw up flander castile
legal gun owner in his car telling the
cop i do have my legal gun and the cop
panics and shoots them anyway
that's messed up but then you have you
know these circumstances where
in that one viral video where these two
cops are trying to subdue a guy and then
he runs to his door
grabs the gun and just shoots both these
cops like crazy
that that's that's real life these
things happen i think is that the video
where the one cops just starts this he
lets out this blood-curdling
shriek and then it's just silent after
he gets i mean yeah that's that's some
chilling stuff
it is but you have to but you have but
you have to be aware of that kind of
thing and that kind of danger before you
can really
offer any sort of nuanced opinion on
these kinds of matters and
now think about it so for for all the
things i've seen
wrong like you mentioned was the michael
scott case yeah walter scott walter
scott sorry
michael scott is from the office yes
great act not him
uh walter scott was running away and the
cop just looks and then puts a bull in
his back he went to prison for that
he got held accountable i'm glad to hear
it for all these other stories you got
to understand the nuance
and the way i usually put it is i hear
the left say oh the likelihood they get
shot or whatever is slim than none and
i'm like i i
don't know i hear you i hear you so what
you're saying is you think these guys
should take a job that doesn't pay very
well has crappy hours
and every day is a lottery ticket where
if their number comes due they die
i'm sorry man i'm gonna give them a
weapon and say in the event that happens
because we're asking you to do this on
our behalf
you defend yourselves and that means
there's gonna be some some there's gonna
be
accidents there's gonna be bad people
and it means it's a part of life
we got we got to figure it out when when
that dude shot you know walter scott in
the back
he got arrested and charged for it he
got he got held accountable thankfully
because of video
so we need to make sure we're being
reasonable in the event with george
floyd i think it's i think it's
interesting i think they overcharged the
guy
yeah and i think the the activists want
retribution i don't think justice is the
right word for it i think the question
is was he defending himself i agree with
you because
their job is they need to defend
themselves but was was
chauvin defending himself he wasn't it
didn't seem like it no
and and i i definitely think the media
in the left makes it out to be
substantially worse than it was
especially after we saw the body camera
footage
floyd's saying take me out put me on the
ground put me on the ground things like
that
but i do think there is a legitimate
question where we can have a debate
about manslaughter not murder
the murder charges i think are going to
fall off because i think third degree
murder is that you intended to cause
harm that resulted in death
but i don't think look so we can pull
this up we have this tweet from brandon
stahl
you can actually see this is from the
mpd training manual apparently
it shows the cops putting their knee on
the neck of
another officer it's not a real uh you
know submission
this is a training video youtube don't
demonetize us this is this is the police
training material
you can see they're trained to do this
yeah and they're told to do it because
they say place the subject in the
recovery position to alleviate
positional asphyxia
the point of putting their knee on the
neck is specifically to stop them from
suffocating
the question is george floyd was put in
the custody of these officers when when
the officers assume custody of an
individual they have a responsibility
now
their responsibility to make sure that
they're not causing the person harm or
creating undue stress
and you know checking on this individual
i will say the reason is a tough
question is because it was a matter of
uh it was nine minutes to me that's
crazy that's a long time to be kneeling
on somebody nine minutes
but it was three minutes where floyd was
unresponsive what was
what should he have done and what was he
doing and what are the real questions
we're trying to ask
ultimately i'm not sure prison solves
anything maybe maybe he gets
kicked off the force because they were
like we need people who aren't going to
be they're going to be more attuned to
this
but prison time i mean i think that's
bold
i mean prison time
it might make some people feel better
but i mean
let's be real no matter how this shakes
out which you know
i think we're all in agreement that it's
not going to be what a lot of people
wanted
the people seeking retribution want it
to be and you know we
i think they want first degree murder
but you know what they're already primed
now because as soon as as the lesser
charges go through
they're going to say this is yet another
instance of of
the racist uh system in america you know
uh
being unjust toward toward black
americans
and um you know i i i'm trying to
stave off uh this this creeping nihilism
but you know
there are a lot of instances where i
feel like you know there's just
you can't i should i guess i shouldn't
say can't but it
i don't i just don't know how you
how you walk back from all of this
generation well this is
what's funny because i tend to be more
pessimistic but i also feel like well if
you become demoralized and you become
depressed then they whoever they is
um they then they win right but then you
know i mean i i'm
i spend a lot of time down in atlanta
now and um
you know at my job which i which i won't
mention because i don't you know i don't
want people to
to track me down and be crazy but you
know
it's my job to enforce a dress code
let's let's say that
and so the minute that somebody shows up
and they're not in dress code and they
happen to to not be white they
immediately jump to well well you're a
racist even though and they
then they're like what about that person
oh you mean that black person wearing a
blazer and dress shoes that
is in dress code okay if there are black
people inside then how is it racist that
you can't get inside
but that's where people that's where
their mind jumps
do they call you racist yeah oh oh uncle
tom they you know they call me a house
negro except they don't they use the
other n word
um you know it's just the most one of
the guys i work with is south africa i'm
like how much blacker can you get
than someone from africa and yet they
call him the same kind of things when
he's when he
you know we're just but
it's but it's deeper than that though
because you know i think about the the
average life of a
say a black kid in america and you know
they they wake up in the morning they go
to school and what are their educators
telling them
oh america is racist you know civil war
abe lincoln mlk
they you know their favorite athletes
their favorite comedians their favorite
musicians they all have this same sort
of message they go on social media they
watch the news it's the same message
it's
you know their their relatives their
friends and family are all saying the
same things to them so this is a
constant inundation of this world view
that says that white people
are evil america is racist and this is
generations and generations now
and i you know again in my darker
moments i say how do you combat that
you know and and you know someone like
someone like me comes along
and here's and here's another irony of
it because when i was a kid it was the
other
you know people think that i was born
with a silver spoon in my mouth that is
not true at all
but you know i we grew up in you know
around working class you know sort of
more
on the poor and and poorer into things
and
because of the way i carry myself the
fact that i had the temerity to
turn in my homework on time or at least
to try uh i was accused of acting white
and now what's happening is that you
have this educated class now
this intelligentsia this bourgeois class
or whatever of of white but also black
people who are also saying the same
things
about you know if you're punctual if
you're disciplined
if you're a rugged individualist then
you're striving for whiteness if you're
looking for
a financial success or whatever then
you're striving for whiteness so now
you're getting it from the bottom
and from the top as well and so i don't
know where you
you have to find some way to break out
of that and escape from it and i don't
know
what those avenues are for people have
you seen that thing from the smithsonian
yes
before i even explain yes well let's
let's break it down for the audience tim
break it down
where it's like scheduling is whiteness
and like being on time and working hard
saving for the future i saw that
and i thought to myself if those aren't
familiar like the smithsonian had this
chart where it's like a graphic
explaining that
like i said working hard is considered a
a trait of being white i'm like wow
white supremacist would completely agree
but what i what i thought when i saw
this was have they never been to like an
african country
like people have jobs people have
schedules people work hard people say
for the future
they're racists they literally think
that like these countries in africa that
function that have employees in
businesses and that are predominantly
black
don't have schedules yeah don't save
money in a bank also
you have to imagine that whoever created
that that poster
i'm sure they had to meet a deadline at
some point
you know they they had to they had to be
able to compose
uh uh compose their sentences properly
and make their points
you know it's follow their their their
schedules their their schedules it's
it's this um
i mean i had an argument uh with one of
my harlem roommates actually
and he actually was mad at me i was
talking about striving for a financial
success he's like he's like man that's
just
he reacted man that's just another way
of striving for trying to be white man
and i was like
there's a lot of nigerian and japanese
businessmen i think who disagree with
that notion
you know but how but how sinister is it
how insidious is it
that these people who claim to be
fighting on my behalf
say that anything that you could
possibly do to improve your life
means that you are not really who you
are
you know it's it's it's and people and
people can't see it because i mean
that's the power of i don't know
the leftist brand the democrat brand
whatever you want to say but you know i
mean i left the democratic party two
years ago because
i began to say you know what these
people are not they're not in my corner
they're telling me all these things that
are going to lead to a terrible life and
a life of
of dependency and and insecurity and yet
they still want me to vote for the
politicians that are pushing forward
these same things you know and
you know i i i shudder to think of how
much money i could have right now if i
just
just decided to say you know what
everyone's racist and and i'm a victim
and uh and don't paypal exactly
give me a book deal or you know or you
know nike please give me money
mcdonald's please give me money this is
the funny thing about when they say like
grifter and all that stuff
it's like dude do you like you realize
the corporations support the leftist
narrative if i wanted a big sponsorship
from big brands who paid big bucks
and i was really intending on grifting
people i'd just be a leftist
yeah that's like all of these major
brands change all their logos to
rainbows and
you know candy canes and all that stuff
and i'm i'm sitting here
i'll be honest it's not like this show
is like far right conservative or
anything like that
but i'm just not i just no certainly not
apparently not though
then what am i doing here right down the
middle i mean that's the funny thing too
it's like
the centrist doesn't exist to any of
these people no it's funny so like i i
i have uh uh you know some descriptions
of me say tim pool has been variously
variously described as left wing and
right wing it's like
maybe it's because i'm a centrist like
like we
some i think there are some things
conservatives got right i think
they're the ones standing up for free
speech for the most part right now you
definitely got conservatives who are
pro-cancel culture
they'll say they aren't but they would
they would want to cancel people if they
had the chance yeah for the time being
there are more moderates and
conservatives who are saying hey don't
ban speech
the left the neo-liberal left for the
most part is anti-speech shout out to
jacob i know a lot of people don't
aren't fans of them but for a leftist
socialist publication
they've defended free speech for some
really important people saying
right they'll come for us the moment
they cut you let them go for them so i
can respect that
i don't care where you are in the
spectrum if we believe in freedom
individuality
you know self-respect and all that stuff
or like a um responsibility i think it's
just easier way to put it
all of that's kind of going out the
window these days like the whole the
whole idea is that
i guess on the left you are
it's a really it's a really horrible way
to live you are responsible
let me put it this way you have to do
what the left wants you to do and if you
screw up it's your fault
you get no benefits for being an
individual you have no right to work
they create villains to keep you in line
but the moment you make a mistake
then you are an individual then they do
sacrifice then they do come for you
you know what i mean yeah it's um i was
actually
attended what they called a salon this
was in new york city
it was hosted by by an actor friend of
mine
a brilliant guy excuse me and he showed
this video
where this guy explicitly said people
tend to focus
too much on the individual we need to
focus more on the collective and i was
like
well yeah i was very silent during that
entire
affair people were like what do you
think black guy i'm like i mean this is
one of those things where you have to
walk in they had these um
these bracelets at the door that and you
had to put one bracelet on for each
mark of privilege that you had so you
know if if if your if your parents went
to college
wear a bracelet if you if you are able
to vote
wear this privilege bracelet you know if
if you have a mother and a father it's
just like
there's this this i mean it's a secular
religion man there's all these like
they're self-castigation it's just it's
it's it's so insane to me i took them i
can't see it i took the privilege test
and i scored very very poorly oh i'm
sorry tim
very poorly yeah so it's like it it asks
you a lot of
a lot of questions are you religious you
know are you white are you male it's
like what's your gender what's your race
what's your religion
what was your family's income level and
all these things have you ever been a
victim of this a victim of that
and i'm going through it and it was like
it's it's like you are very
underprivileged or whatever and i was
like i never knew that
i never knew that like i i guess i
understood growing up we weren't rich
but it never mattered also what what is
what is the right amount of privilege
you know what nobody ever really dictate
or
or quantifies what that is you're over
privileged or you're underprivileged but
no
what is the perfect amount of privilege
that we're that we are allowed to have
uh i don't know because i know you can't
quantify it that's the problem i know
people that were born in pretty much the
same situation strong family
and part of like they looked like their
surroundings so like that familiarity
bias i don't think it's a racial thing i
think it's like if you're familiar with
your surroundings you know
someone looks like me and a weinstein
basically says this yeah yeah
and but they're like losers no offense
to you guys if you can hear me out there
and you know who you are
um but they never made much of
themselves but they had that they still
had that privilege
and then i know people that i had i was
a huge nerd i mean look at me
i was like pushed around in school i
would talk like this in school and
people be like you're
get out of my you know weirdos it was
hard
but i had i had some privilege but you
have to strive to make something
yourself regardless of
what kind of privilege so the privilege
is not gonna it's not gonna give you the
success you have to take that
no you know you know i i read something
interesting uh i was talking to a friend
of mine this guy i know
and he said that he was shocked he was
not that he said
it's shocking that we don't teach
juneteenth in
schools and i said bro they taught me
juneteenth in school
i think the issue is your school didn't
teach you juneteenth
so i don't know where you went to school
in the city
yeah we we talked about it i'm not gonna
pretend like the school celebrated or
anything
but i remember like opening up the book
and then reading about you know this
history
and i think the issue was like where he
grew up in his community
perhaps his community didn't like
there's certain stories and certain
things they didn't think were as
relevant so they ignore them
it's not like you're going to teach
literally every child every grade school
kid about every bit of history
and i thought it was interesting that he
said that because i was like first of
all it shows you that your
experience is you think your experience
is the world's experience
you think because they didn't teach you
that i wasn't taught or other schools
don't
that's just you man yeah and it's it's
really funny because uh i don't know
you're familiar with ryan long the
comedian
yeah i know who he is but he's got a new
bit and it's brilliant where it's
basically a therapist telling the woman
no matter what she does wrong
she should tell the world to change
instead of her so he's like
when she's like you know i can't seem to
find a good guy he's like have you
considered writing an article telling
men what they can do better but
it's a good point because when i hear
people say like why aren't schools
teaching this i'm like bro they do
not all of them and not yours so maybe
there's an argument
but then why don't we teach the holiday
more you know what i mean like you
choose what you think matters too you
see the problem
i'm not here to to disrespect anybody's
struggles or plights
and i also don't know what what history
is more
important based on privilege is the
holodomor ignored because it was white
people oh i'm sorry
the coalition of communities of color
said that slavs slavic people are
are people of color now so does that
mean that we are ignoring
a genocide of people of color in in the
holodomor by not teaching this to great
great school children or does it make
sense because juneteenth is literally an
american
you know a holiday in 47 states and it
should be more prominent in this country
well these are these are just
conversations well yeah
like i work backwards right so we were
talking before we came on air you know
i'm
binging a lot of thomas soul right now
and he goes in
on what he calls intellectuals the
intelligentsia
and how they and and visions of the
world
you know i think everyone should read a
conflict of visions to sort of get a
grasp on
it's its souls attempt to highlight the
the roots of the ideological uh uh
fishers of our time
and he talks about uh the intelligentsia
in terms of journalism and journalists
and how they tend to filter out
uh facts that are inconvenient to to
their own vision so you know why don't
we teach the holodomor
well it's it's inconvenient to the
leftist vision of the world
you know and juneteenth isn't so they're
bringing it up now and then and then
um talking about who you know they're
not they're not teaching this in schools
i mean i remember
there was some tweet about um uh
people like to forget about emmett till
i'm like who is who has not been told
about emmett till
everyone knows who emmett till is i
don't know who is not teaching that um
teaching that but again it's like you
know who is he
are you serious yeah no see this is a
good point though like wow well so so
emmett till was this kid uh who
basically he was accused of whistling at
a white woman this was back in the the
50s i want to say
and he got the crap beat out about beat
out of him you can find pictures online
of his corpse it's it's beaten beyond
recognition
you know they they beat him they threw
him in you know they threw him in a body
of water i mean it was it was awful it
was horrible
but every person i've met except for ian
apparently knows
that story and he's but this idea like
we're not teaching this is is wrong the
last thing i want to say just working
back a little bit
is that juneteenth june should be black
history month the one stereotype
the one stereotype out that i will
accept about black folks is that we do
not like the cold
they gave us the shortest coldest month
to celebrate
and all to celebrate our history why is
that nice and that's just ridiculous to
me but but even
better when you said june june should be
black history month i'm like that is the
month of june
exactly it makes sense i'm launching a
campaign right now
no i'm kidding can you guys briefly and
forgive my ignorance explain
juneteenth and the holdemore can you
explain those really quick
oh god hold on moore basically uh stalin
uh lots of policies that led to uh
starvation of millions of ukrainians the
new york times
famously under a journalist named walter
durrante who has an award named for him
and
this guy later won a pulitzer prize
which the new york times has not
rescinded
he deliberately filtered out as i said
before the information about the hall of
demore
uh and meanwhile there was another
british journalist and i
i i wish i remembered his name but he
was actually reporting what was going on
and he got smeared and
so impoverished long story short holla
de moore was a genocide of
ukrainians the soviet union took all
their food away from him basically and
they all just started starving to death
it's brutal horrific juneteenth i've
heard a lot about it but i
would love for some clarification oh i i
don't remember what it is it's like it's
like the
emancipation it's the it's it's
essential it's the june 19th the
celebration of
the the day i think i could be wrong the
day the
uh the union marched in texas and
enforced the end of slavery officially
it was like the last person who was
still enslaved got like
finally and there's a move to make it a
national holiday
so interestingly in more recent times
47 states already have it as a holiday
and i got to be honest i
i think we should absolutely as a nation
celebrate juneteenth i really really
it's a significant event
it's it's independence day man and i've
heard the leftists talk about how it's
like today
you know we finally said this is the end
of slavery and i'm like dude absolutely
like it was a horror it's a horrible
thing and i'm all about
you know more celebrations for america
and the things we've done right so the
fourth of july i'm down
you mean i get another one a month
before to celebrate what i'm saying
do you know do you know do you know how
much barbecuing is going to happen
if we put black history month in june
all right man come on man let's
just just make it make it happen comment
make it happen
i'll tell you i'll tell you the issue i
take with a lot of the critical race
theory a lot of the leftist approach to
things
is like i'm you know i did an hour-long
documentary around ferguson
and pruitt igo and public housing and
the racial covenants of saint louis
systemic racism institutional racism and
and you know when i
when i sit down with conservatives and
trump supporters and actually have
conversations
as like human beings sitting down
together to have discussions we actually
come to an understanding of each other's
views and politics and understandings
and if there's something like ian wasn't
familiar with juneteenth i'm not content
to be the expert i probably got some of
it wrong but i'll just be like oh so
it's basically this
so when i talk to conservatives treating
them as
humans and good people who just you know
maybe don't understand
then all of a sudden they're like oh oh
i didn't know that that's interesting
like surprise surprise when you actually
sit down with someone have a
conversation with them
like oh they may still be like well i
disagree with these particular points
so the issue i take is we just basically
said on this show
juneteenth should be a national holiday
we should have tons of barbecuing
and the problem with a lot of the
mainstream left is that they need the
conflict
like when you mentioned your roommate
who said you know you know you're just
trying to like act white or whatever
that was
it's like they've they've created the
villain that those of us who are
fighting for civil rights and have for a
long time in social justice
are trying to do away with this idea
that people are villains based on race
we want to be like no no people are
villains because they're bad people with
bad ideas
and they want to hurt you but there are
good people of all different races there
are bad people involved in
different races but i think the people
who want power in politics
and sometimes it's republicans i think
republicans have a lot a lot of faults
but democrats absolutely love using race
as a wedge
to drive uh a push for power and i'll
give you a really good example
they complain the republican party is
too white it's a bunch of white men they
say
and then when the rnc had several
prominent black
they insulted them and called them all
the awful racial slurs and i'm like
so you asked them to do better the
republicans were like absolutely you're
right
and then you insulted the people who
spoke like dude
i can complain about mitch mcconnell and
lindsey graham and the weak
republicans the phrase republican
leadership is an oxymoron
i think everybody watches know i say
this all the time the democrats are
something else
you know i grew up in chicago and i feel
it's probably one of the reasons why i
have a bias very much so against
democrats i think that should be obvious
to anybody
so i grew up in a democrat-run city i
was personally screwed over by democrats
as somebody who was
you know essentially a liberal living in
the city republicans didn't affect me
anyway i watch mitch mcconnell and what
does he do he goes slow around their
democrats and then he obstructs things
i was talking to a democrat friend and
she was just saying all he does is sit
on things and stop things from happening
and i'm like right and the democrats
actually do stuff they do stuff that's
either bad for us
or they do like or they don't do what we
want to do and they do bad things i'll
put it that way
like you get joe biden two thousand
dollar checks everyone says yes fine
they agree and then he doesn't do and he
doesn't bomb syria instead
and again i know you know donald trump
missile strikes drone strikes all the
bad stuff too
there's a lot to uh unpack breaking down
all of that stuff but ultimately
i really do feel like the democrats are
worried if
we actually had the conversation where i
was like oh i don't really care about
race or gender and stuff i think people
are you know should be treated
respectfully
and and you know we should come together
and fight for common causes particularly
class issues
oh that's bad news for them well i'm i'm
convinced
that most of us in this country agree
on a lot of things there are some hot
button issues like like abortion for
instance that
are just really emotional and people
have very divergent views on that but i
think we agree
on more things than we are led to
believe and i say all the time get off
of social media
uh get off of don't stop watching the
news and just start
talking to people and you'll see just
how you know when i
when i uh left uh when i left new york
city
uh the the dystopian wasteland that it's
now become
um and i and i went to a city like
atlanta and
you know i was so heartened by just
talking to people who are not in this
progressive bubble who they have
they're connected to life in a way that
people in new york city are just are
just not and they have concerns that
that you know
that that new yorkers just don't that
aren't that aren't really they aren't
really privy to
and going back to your point about about
democrats you know one of the reasons
that that motivated my
my uh deregistering from the party you
know i mean as a black person you're
just expected to be a democrat but
you i i you can't honestly ignore
the fact that you have all of these uh
cities that have
uh large black populations that um
that are afflicted with blight all kinds
of disparities you know between rich
and poor you know crime and they're run
by democrats in many instances they're
run they've been run by democrats for
decades and yet people still keep
supporting them so
and and you know and i got backlash on
twitter when i'm like you know well
i'm not going to vote for democrats just
automatically they they they're taking
our vote for granted
they they piss on your face and they're
telling you it's raining they do it all
the time and and black people just eat
it up and i just i'm just
you know i'm all about black empowerment
but for me my empowerment is
you know not not automatically
subscribing to any one world view or any
party it's like you know you want to
earn my vote then earn my vote don't
just
assume that i'm gonna go there and you
can just say things and be like oh white
people white people white people and i'm
gonna be like
oh okay yeah i'll just go along with it
that guy i'll tell you what i see
i see a big part of the problem is right
so you
said everyone you've met knows about
emmett till ian didn't i was talking
about my friend who said you know i'm
surprised people don't teach about
juneteenth and i'm like they taught us
when we were in school
yeah the irony what these people these
these progressives and these leftists
and many of them i get it good-natured
righteous indignation the problems
they're talking about are in
democrat-run cities like you mentioned
so when you complain about police
brutality
you're not talking about rural idaho
you're talking about new york city
when you mention stop and frisk new york
city when you talk about racially
segregated neighborhoods like redlining
that was chicago the red line it's the
train lines called the red line they
called it redlining
these things were all happening in
cities run by democrats for like a
hundred years
so maybe maybe you got issues i look
i've been to
conservative parts of the south very
racist places i've been to i've been a
lot of them
uh people people have their own world
views based on where they live and i
think one of the issues is that
these these progressives live in cities
and then they treat the whole country
like a city block in manhattan and they
do it with the media
like the media gets into all the cities
it's even
like culture politics downstream from
culture you know fantastic
concepts they'll go to a bar in
manhattan and then attribute their
experience
to rural idaho and then they'll make a
commercial and show it on tv in rural
idaho and start
messing with people and it's it's so
incidental it's so
having spent 15 years in new york i mean
you
it's such uh it's such an enveloping
experience
and even i have to stop myself from
from um i have to remind myself that not
you know this is just a really unique
place to be and not everywhere is like
this and not everywhere should be
like this and you know new yorkers
you know they think they're smarter than
everybody else and they think that
everywhere should be like new york but
then when you leave new york people like
man like new york cause i don't care
you're from new york
right you know yankee yada yada like
they just they just don't care nobody
thinks that
nobody thinks that new yorkers are as
cool as new yorkers do
yeah were you in manhattan oh yeah
people in manhattan were like brooklyn's
not new york
well but everyone everyone and everyone
in new york agrees staten island is in
new york even people from stanford
well but but also there's this i mean
it's i've spoken to people
brilliant people who you know they say
for instance you know i don't like those
fly over country people people who have
grown up in the lap of affluence and
privilege
say i don't like these but i'm like dude
as soon as you leave
manhattan the rest of the state is
pretty red
right you know i mean you you can go
upstate you know and you can fight you
can see trump signs i mean you know
maybe even a confederate flag or two you
know maybe yeah and
it's so i'm like dude you're you're
you're even
they're bubbles they're they're they're
in their games you're crapping on your
own people they're they're in bubbles
and the bubbles are actually getting
smaller and smaller in physical space
but denser in population
yeah so you go outside new york even a
couple miles
it's red yeah you start seeing a bunch
of republicans and trump supporters
and i'll say you know i'll say this too
um just in terms of the the coveted
response i mean that
that in and of itself i mean i feel like
i have a bit of a unique experience in
terms of
having lived in the city at the start of
the pandemic i was one of the people i
mean i was sanitizing my mail and my
groceries back in january and february
man i was
i was stocking up on food i was telling
my friends and family i still have
nitrile gloves left over from when i
from when i
uh stocked up on supplies and someone
twitter was like so that means you
robbed
a medical professionals of like much
needed gear i was like oh my god
but but you know but then you go to you
were saying back then man they were but
don't wear them as they said
that's crazy yeah thanks uh in general
but then when you go to um a place like
atlanta where it's it's way more relaxed
and then you come back to new york i
mean new york right now
i mean i'm in this chat group on on
twitter uh and it's a lot of
lefties and liberals who are against the
lockdown measures
and a lot of us are in new york a lot of
us met up in new york last time i was
there
and i'm you know if you live in new york
city you are
inundated every moment of your life once
you leave your your
your apartment your shoe box with you
know there's
arrows on the ground telling you where
to walk there's little circles telling
you where to stand you know inside and
outside there's
there's advertisements everywhere
telling you to wear your mask there's
train announcements there's digital
advertise there's it's every it's
everywhere get you know get your vaccine
stay away from each other
mask up don't wear it underneath your
nose where i mean it's just it's
constant it's constant it's constant
then you go to atlanta
and i mean i make this point on twitter
like you can go get a lap dance
in atlanta right now and no one cares
you know i mean i work at a nightclub
down there no one's wearing masks inside
because they want to get out and party
and like they it's not that they don't
care it's just that
you know it's it's just a whole
different vibe then you come to new york
and everyone is like walking around
outside with their masks on and they're
just they're they're afraid and they're
not socializing and it's it's a totally
different
world but they don't know it because
they're in this bubble in new york
and they just and they watch the news
all the time and they just they
don't know look you look at like uh in
response to taxes opening up
you get michael moore and keith
olbermann saying take the vaccines away
from texas
everyone's like die yeah yeah yeah
exactly and it's like dude you realize
like
just just like a little bit less than
half of texas votes democrat like they
like it was very close between
you know was it beto and ted cruz were
there running
it was like pretty close and so a bunch
of even leftists and democrats were like
guys please there are democrats who live
in texas you don't want any of them to
die and they're like
there was one tweet from this guy he was
like furthermore republicans shouldn't
die either simply because they voted for
a republican that's insane
that these prominent progressives say
this but look at you know look at who
these people are limousine liberal keith
oberman and michael you know michael
moore they live in the the bosom of
wealth
in ultra liberal cities i don't exactly
know where they're living right now but
they're totally
in this weird bubble surrounded by other
weirdos
who think this is popular opinion and
even regular like
even media democrats who have all of
their biases we always complain about
them we're like dude
dude come on like we don't want
republicans to die from the virus
yeah we can complain about the governor
and stuff but like florida's been open
the whole time and i'm like you're here
dude like i agree man
i think it's just one of the problems is
that
you have personalities like this like
like older men like mike moore
who it's the definition of a grifter you
know what i mean
they love to point the fingers in my
direction and i'm like dude i'll just
say whatever i feel like saying
michael moore trying to rile people up
to the point where he actually says take
the vaccines away
or maybe they shouldn't have vaccines
and keith olbermann saying they
shouldn't have vaccines
i'm like not even not even leftists were
like
saying that because you actually have
people on the left who have opinions
i disagree with some of their opinions i
agree with some of their opinions and i
think many of them genuinely believe
what they believe
but i look at people like older men or
more when they say say stuff like that
i'm like they don't believe any of this
they're just saying what they think will
rile up enough people to get a bunch of
retweets and it worked
they're they're part of they're part of
the unquote intelligentsia
and you know i also notice a trend among
a lot of these people i mean
i often say that twitter is a place
where you you you can get away with
saying things that would get you punched
in the face in real life
and a lot of these so-called radicals or
whatever there's a
there's a guy that i follow um i i
follow him explicitly because i disagree
with him so vehemently he's a socialist
i'm not going to say what his name is
but you know he
he's he's tweeting the most overheated
hyperbolic melodramatic rhetoric about
you know we have to overthrow the
capitalistic system and
you know every time there's a black
person holiday he's like you know
malcolm x
and then you watch a video you know and
he's just the most
i mean how i mean i don't know how to
describe it but you know he just he
sounds like this
i'm like of course you sound like that
because when it when when when the
revolution goes down
you ain't going to be nowhere to be
found you you know you
like if you're he's going to be one of
those people who's like he's going to
have a gun and be like oh i don't
i don't know what to do with with this
and oh people are punching people like i
don't know what to do
it's the softest people who have the
most s to talk
it's all like every time you know start
like i've been i've been getting more i
became more of a gun person in the past
year because
most because of the riots yes you have
i'm finding bullets just randomly around
the house by the way it's it's actually
pretty hilarious
well they're not it's not random it's
not random okay
you know what it is it is strategic but
i won't get into too much detail because
you know
security at the house and everything
like that but it isn't random and i
started you know going to the range we
mentioned this earlier in the show
like give someone a handgun who's never
fired before
man will they not be able to make it
work and so the people who
there's a lot of new gun owners a lot of
a lot of liberals went out and bought
guns and i hope hope hope hope any of
you listening who are new gun owners
you go take some classes you go to a
local range
you ask people to give you all the tips
in the world because
you do like you need to respect you know
like what it means to be
a well verse and the rules the safety uh
how to actually shoot when the
revolution comes a lot of these people
who are you know
on the left they're not gonna know how
to operate a gun at all no and so
there's a joke
where a lot of conservatives say this
they were like
i i can't remember exactly what the joke
is i'm sure people listening will know
it but it's something like
you know thank you to all of the uh
liberals who are buying supplies you're
collecting them for the people who own
guns
you know which is like the conservatives
because when it really comes down to it
what are you gonna do you know when when
people are are getting violent
it's it's the craziest thing when i have
these conversations with people and they
don't think anything bad is happening
because we are truly frogs in a pot
boiling i hear a lot of people saying
like tim you were scaremongering about
civil war or whatever and i was like
yeah and then like
800 people stormed into the u.s capitol
building i guess so
was i wrong like i didn't say the
apocalypse was gonna have apocalypse was
gonna happen and like we were gonna see
meteor swap in the sky and the whole
planet was gonna blow up
i said people are gonna start escalating
the the violence and the tensions
and it's literally happening and i don't
see any reason why it would stop at this
point
because they're still just ramping
things up global civil war
this this fifth i was gonna call fifth
dimensional fifth generational war but
it doesn't have to be a world war
one country yeah but it's like a civil
world war like it's an economic world
war
or a political world war right now it's
it's it's a weird time of upheaval
you know what i mean it's very very it's
weird it's unique
and and i think that's the issue too is
too too much we we have that saying
right those who forget their history are
doomed to repeat it
well there should be another saying
where it's like those who think the
future will be based on the past
100 are fools i don't know it's not a
good quote but you get the idea
right you can't look at 1860s
and be like that's going to happen today
it's like what are you talking about we
have phones
yeah you know what i mean like we have
the internet like there's just
artificial intelligence this is life
yeah seriously and and
nuclear bombs you know it's not gonna be
the same conflict
you know uh back in the day i love
talking about this because it's a point
a lot of people don't realize
could you imagine during the civil war
sending a message from dc to like
fort sumter and you're like how do we
get a message there put it on horseback
and then it'll be there in a week today
it's like let me just text jim
yep you got the message all right
they're moving out it's just like the
instant
instantaneous transmission of
information has changed everything
totally totally
so what we experience is going to be
very very different it's not going to be
you know like the past
yeah you know i don't i don't know how
things are are going to work out i mean
i i
i am curious um what is his name michael
malus who talks about
you know all this chaos is actually good
because on the other side of it
um you know we're going to come out
better for it and maybe maybe he's right
i mean maybe
maybe that's part of why people like me
are popping up because we're saying
more and more of us are saying like no
this is not okay i don't
i'm not okay with the way things are
going um
but at the same time whatever happens in
terms of getting to that place that
whatever that that proverbial better
place might be i mean
maybe that it that actually now that i
think about it that might be another
form of utopianism in a way it's like
you know what's on the other side of
that it's no place
you ever watched star trek i watched the
next generation like back in the day
best one of the best shows ever made one
of my all-time favorite shows
and i'm just like i look at this vision
of the future where
you've got people of all different race
and species
they work together there's alliances and
i'm just imagining like
this this air this 90s era liberalism
that truly believed in
treating people based on the content of
their character resulted in this idea
and it wasn't even 90s i mean you go
back to the original star trek and they
had like the first interracial kiss
right you know right yeah
wrong one oh no oh they're all going to
come they're going to come after me now
yeah
but so so it was always fairly
progressive and then in the 90s
it it brings about this this this vision
of a future where people are all getting
along and judging people on the content
of their character
could you imagine star trek today where
it's like
an alien race comes in they're like how
many arms you have okay you have no
armed privilege but you are psychic you
have psychic privilege
and it's like a show based on that world
view would just be
it would just be like the most painfully
dystopian nightmare yeah not a good idea
for a future
i like this idea where we're all just
like we're gonna get on a spaceship and
go to space i don't care what you look
like
can you press the button great let's do
it you know what i mean i feel like the
the the previous show that you mentioned
however even though nobody would watch
it i guarantee you would get at least a
90
on rotten tomatoes i i i shouldn't be
showered with awards
oh yeah it would be like one percent
audience rating but like 100
certified friends exactly exactly i
think i think we should uh film a sketch
like that but not be explicit in the
comedy of it
like literally just make woke star trek
as like a short like three minute little
little bit
and just see if that happens take it
seriously
take it seriously yeah yeah bill like
the captain has to be
like a disabled person of color who's
non-binary
and you know because a privilege is not
going to be given to the white male or
whatever and then
a certain species comes in and it's like
a floating mass and it has no legs it
has no color and so the like it has
no known privilege you know
that would be excellent i think i think
the um i think
the the captain should be oh gosh it
should be a
a fat black transgendered paraplegic in
a hijab
that should be the captain of this of
this star trek series
well i think you know taking it
seriously uh
all of the cultures and everything of
the united states of of this i'm not the
united states of the
of the world coming together and i think
that's actually a legitimate
uh uh depiction of a future captain
i think that's like the vision they have
for it you know south park did it as a
bunch of olive skinned bald people who
went
future people well let's let's let's
let's we gotta
you know we skipped over cuomo basically
but it's fine because that conversation
was way was great was better
not in my opinion we got we got to do
this story though we have to
from usa today burger king uk under fire
for tweeting i can't read this quote
i'm gonna break the quote up so that no
one claims it came from me
women belong and this is burger king in
the kitchen and that's what burger king
said
all right now i break it up that way
because someone's going to try and pull
out of context and try and make it seem
like i'm the one saying that
i do not believe women belong in the
kitchen i'm actually
not i'm i'm a proponent of uh women
succeeding in the workplace and getting
beautiful salaries and
you know running companies uh uh uh more
to the point
we can all be proud of the fact that the
military-industrial complex is now run
by women
exactly great strides in blowing up
children women are killers too everyone
oh yeah fantastic you know but to be
serious
they can be you look at how the prison
system handles women and they treat
women with they get less harsher
penalties more lenient sentences than
men absolutely
no women can be murderers and criminals
and all that really awful stuff too
they can be warmongers and and uh you
know weapons manufacturers and all that
stuff
and burger king thought it would be a
good idea to claim that
they believed women they believe belong
in the kitchen
so usa today writes burger king's
attempt to highlight gender disparity in
the restaurant industry
with a provocative tweet appears to have
backfired
on monday which is also international
sorry on international women's day
burger king tweeted this out
yup yup some i i just i can't believe it
a bunch of like nationalists and like
pro-western personalities are saying
like
thank you burger king for saying what
needs to be said
this is exactly what women need to
understand and it's like oh
geez and the left is saying you know
apparently burger king is defending
themselves they're like
it was a good tweet that is bringing
attention to the issue that
only 20 of culinary professionals are
women
and then the left is just like so why
did you have to tweet
this sentence which is not in any way
conveying the message you think it is if
if if it had been
me i would have uh
i would have said that uh i just would
have called myself booker queen
for a day and then maybe that would have
been okay yeah
that's a good idea parker queen called
the burger queen just burger queen for a
day that's a good idea they should hire
you for marketing
i don't think they should but i saw and
i was like this is
this is hilarious and of course my my my
first thought was uh
i mean you know i i we got to keep a fam
family friendly it's it's so
it's so difficult for me but but it's
it's just
it's just this this idea that um
you know it's like well i i guess
they they could be in in the kitchen if
if they
truly want to be what if they're
choosing to be in
in the kitchen you know of course when i
let them out
that's right women have been fighting
for thousands of years
to to get out of the kitchen and fight
the patriarchy with a single tweet
burger king is trying to put them back
in the kitchen i know i know how dare
they no but
it's even funny too like so what burger
king is basically saying is that
culinary professionals tend to be men
and i'm like even even to that regard
like
is it possibly because we have
socialized to the point where we're
telling women not to take these jobs and
to be professionals and go and work for
bigger corporations
like we have been screaming to our
children
you know particularly young young girls
be the ceo
be the high-powered attorney be the
executive and so
i mean these things have consequences so
now we're 20 years later
and you have a bunch of women who are
going to school specifically for jobs
that will make them a lot of money and
give them a lot of power in corporations
not culinary arts i think i think for a
lot of people
working as a chef in like the culinary
industry it's very much about a passion
for cooking and baking and creating food
and when you take when you take these
kids and you tell them you won't be
respected you won't make money don't do
it
what happens you get a bunch of people
who are like i'm gonna do what i what i
have fun doing and what i enjoy doing
you have the stigma for the most part
for young women being told
you have to do more because you won't
have respect and let you take these jobs
men aren't hearing that so they're like
i love cooking i'm gonna go cook well
it's it's the strangest phenomenon and
you know i'm at
an age now where i i see a lot of uh new
mothers and
i i become
disturbed on their behalf because they
actually feel
guilty that they want to spend more time
with their children
and i'm thinking to myself isn't the
whole point of all of this is to
is to provide you with options so that
if you choose to you can stay home
and i i i think this also speaks to
something
deeper and it's sort of related to covet
in a way like the the
the instinct that so many people seem to
have to want to stay
just stay indoors and stay away from
just living their lives
this devaluation of life i mean my my
thing is
yeah you know it's great if you have all
these degrees and all these
accomplishments
but hey i mean every every new father
i've met has said yeah
you know i i i i
got to keep working i wish i could stay
i wish i could stay home and be with my
kids
like they understand the sacrifice that
they're making but i i don't find as
many women who
who understand that sort of cost benefit
now and i i wonder if it's because
they've been told all their lives that
they need to
succeed and i'm thinking to myself well
we've known you know you can't take it
with you you can't take all your degrees
and all your money with you but your
children do live on
after you yeah i was doing these um
these are shakespeare sonnets and a lot
of them
have to deal have to do with uh just
fertility
and uh um carrying on your your legacy
and your lineage and they're very wise
you know
they're these 14 line poems and within
each of them
you know he's addressing you know
somebody and at least in this first
chunk of them
he's talking about you know well you're
young now but you're not always going to
be young
and when one of the best ones he says
you know well
when you are old if you have children
then your your own youth and that and
the joyous time that you had in your
youth will be reflected back to you and
you can and you
and that youth will live and your own
youth will live forever through the
youth of your children
actually call passing your wealth down
to your child's succession
and that's success i mean the word
success comes when you
succeed you're sending all of your
things to the next generation but even
then it's like you know even if we're
just talking about material wealth i
mean what other kinds of wealth are
there there's
you know what your philosophical wealth
your you know emotional wealth
your your ideas your your your your
your philosophies on life and these are
also things that you can pass down to
your children that
that you can't you can't earn in a
workplace or at a university
you know what blows my mind is we hear
about this trope where people are on
their deathbed
and they say you know a person on their
deathbed never wishes they spent more
time at the office
the one thing we always hear is they
wish they spent more time with their
family and their friends and their loved
ones
there's a story i was reading on reddit
long time ago it's about a guy who said
that his
i think it was his grandmother showing
him photos of
uh him and his you know of his uncles
and his aunts or whatever at the grand
canyon or something
and it was just a picture of the grand
canyon that was it and the grandma
looked at it and she was like this is
when you know i was with your aunt and
uncle
at the grand canyon and then she paused
and said why did i take a picture of the
grand canyon
i don't care about the grand canyon i
care about your your
uncle and your aunt or whatever and then
he was like now that was a
the guy wrote the story he was saying
that was like a profound moment for me
where from now on
whenever i do anything the photos are
always of the people i'm with
not the things we've done or the places
we've been to that's peripheral that's
the outside
the memories we have are the people we
love and care about so i'll tell you
what what really freaks me out what i'm
worried about
when we constantly tell women that they
should be
career women that they're they're you
know
there's a feeling some women have of
social stigma i'm not saying all women
i'm not saying it's something that
every woman experiences but i've seen uh
the conversations from from women who
are concerned that if they want to be
just a homemaker they'll be in some ways
socially
inconvenienced or face a detriment like
they could get divorced and then
how do they you know take care of
themselves they won't have respect from
their peers
the issue i see is that men don't have
the same biological limitation on having
kids yeah you could be 50 year old men
have kids but women do have that
limitation
there are ways to mitigate that with
like freezing eggs and things like that
but that is something men don't
experience
so i look at these stories and i'm
wondering if like the reason why
perhaps i don't know i don't think it's
true i'm just it's something to consider
if people want to make sure they're
happy
if maybe the reason why many women
aren't in the culinary arts is because
they're being driven
towards certain professions men won't be
negatively impacted
they can trounce about waste time travel
europe
and just do whatever they want because
they can choose to have a family at you
know any point
yeah and these are there are very
different realities for women
call it the patriarchy call whatever you
want but there are certain privileges to
to to being a man
in terms of how much time you have to
figure things out one of you know
i i have so much compassion
because um
i feel like women have a lot of big
decisions to make about
how they want their lives to be and they
have a limited window in which to make
those decisions and they also
uh need to make those decisions at a
time where they don't really have the
wisdom you know what i mean none of us
have the wisdom when we're 22.
or the wealth yeah yeah yeah you'd be a
50 year old guy and have a bunch of
money in savings but
now i can afford a kid yeah yeah i was
thinking regarding restaurant work
and men and women that in my experience
they would stuff
men in the kitchen and women on the
front in the counter because women were
beautiful and made people want to buy
more and men were
could handle the heat and the grease and
the steam and it's physically
toxic basically so it might be a kind of
job that
men's bodies are just cause like it's
like working in the iron mine like you
put the men in the iron mine well that's
the patriarchy
but it's also biological in a way i
don't know too much i'm sorry
ian are you implying that there's there
are differences between men and women
rhett weinstein
yes yes genetically yes
let's get brett in trouble whenever we
have a sorry
well he's a smart fella so but i do i
would defer to him because it's like
you know if the experts are saying
things but no i think
you're right it's it is biological why
is it that the service industry is
you know tends to be female you go to a
restaurant the
serving staff it's not always not
absolute there's a ton of guys who are
waiters
but you'll tend to see women taking
service jobs
because men will tip more probably or at
least is the assumption they do
so again at my job i see this play out
every single night you have these men
that show up
of any age really a lot of them older
and they're throwing all this money
around and you know
and i don't judge because i see how the
game is played
we have all of these uh these young
servers they're in their their early to
mid 20s
and they're beautiful and they had they
each have their guys come in that
and they have these men wrapped around
their fingers each of these men come in
saying like
yeah i'm here to see you know tatiana or
whatever and
they they think that they you know that
that they are special to her for
for some reason now these guys and
they're kind of scumbag so they're going
off and they're doing whatever they want
with other women too but
right but you know just what you were
talking about you know you know
they they're making so much money um
and you know using whatever that their
whiles are and
also a lot of these guys come in they
show up now i don't know if they're
paying for this company
or if they're actually winning this
company uh you know but you know these
guys with money show up with women that
are half their age and it's a really
it's it's the kind of thing that you
read about and you're like that doesn't
really happen that often but then you
when you see it unfold and it's kind of
weird but it's like i guess i kind of i
kind of get it that's just sort of
how the game is played but it's it's not
something that people like to talk about
because it's not politically correct i'm
like well there's nothing about
about the interaction between the sexes
that is politically correct
yeah i i can't remember what i was
watching but it was like some movie
where there's an old guy who hired a
lady of the night as it were he didn't
want to hook up with her he just like
hung out with her and talked about his
day in his life
and it was basically like the the plot
line was my audiography
he was like 60 years old he didn't have
any friends and he
liked you know he felt he got good
feelings being the
being in the company of a young woman
who he could talk about himself and have
someone listen to him
and i'm like for these guys you call
them scumbags probably
but i don't really see anything all that
nefarious or wrong when they show up to
this club
wanting the attention of these young
women and tipping them and giving them
money or whatever
you can argue it's transactional or
whatever but they're getting what they
want out of it they're getting
emotionally satisfied
they're not doing anything illegal the
women are getting uh
resources for providing that level of
like emotional comfort to these guys
so i'm like hey man and these girls i
mean look we have to walk them to their
cars at night because like i said you
know
not not the best kind of people that
that yeah sometimes but
you know they they're driving nice cars
they live in they live in nice
apartments i'm like look
you know do do what you can while you
got it and you know make make your money
i hope you
you you know you're studying something
else but again that's how the game is
played and
people the people want to shy away from
that but see this is where
the conversation ignites a whole bunch
of the like the
the gender ideologues they're really
angry because
like we were talking about you know
women can only have kids for a certain
amount of time they could
freeze their eggs but there still are
even with freezing eggs there still
still are implications for having kids
at an older age
and so what happens is we end up for a
variety of raisins for the institution
of marriage
and you know i hear a lot from
conservatives they say that women
should uh be in the kitchen get married
young
you know like i hear a lot from
conservatives they say women should get
married young
and the reason conservatives say this is
that as women age
they become less valuable i suppose so
that's the idea
tough word to use but yeah well that's
like
look you look at okay cupid well if
you're talking about the sexual
marketplace
right the biology of trying to be very
very precise with my language here
yeah we we're i think we all are at this
point we talked about it with jack
okcupid put out the data set showing
that men just message 22 year olds
you can think it's bad you can think
it's wrong i personally don't agree
i i don't have that preference for being
a 50 year old man i would not want to be
you know in a relationship with someone
that young i'm just would prefer someone
closer to my age but that's what the
data shows and you can't make
all men change like the ryan long sketch
you know have you considered telling me
writing an article about what women can
do better yeah
like it's not gonna it's not gonna do
anything for you you know what i mean so
this is this is why i think a lot of
people would argue that
marriage came about this way because it
provided security for the woman
right so they have access to that man
who will provide for them
and it's assuming you know the woman
wants these things
they're by all means women can do
whatever they want i just think that's
one of the reasons
it likely came about well it's funny
because then you know i i encounter
women
uh oftentimes and you know i and again i
mean
this it's a byproduct of just being a
curious person and when you and when you
talk to people and you know just
non-judgmentally and you ask them
questions you know and
just over the years i've heard a lot of
women say like you know what
i'm ready to just not go to work anymore
and just be
and just be kept and and not have to
worry about paying bills
they would never say that out in public
you know because they would get shrieked
at by their friends but uh you know i i
do think that maybe more women than not
kind of feel that way
there's actually a um i have to read
this paper but uh it's called the um
the paradox of declining female
happiness whereas
their as their i guess you could say
their rights and freedoms have expanded
over the past
few decades since the 1970s they've been
self-reporting ever-increasing levels of
unhappiness
right i think i read somewhere else that
um about a quarter of women are on some
kind of
um either antidepressant or or or psych
or
psych medication or something like that
and
you know and and again i talk to i talk
to people and you know there's all these
stresses and all these things and they
they're inundated with this news about
how everything's wrong and everything's
oppressed and everything so i'm you know
i just
i don't think it's uh you mentioned like
freedoms
you know that women have attained and
then we see this inverse i don't think
that's the correlation
i do think you can say women's rights
have expanded women's access expanded
but i think social pressures have come
along with it
right and responsibilities on top of
that you know so
you know the way i see it is the higher
levels of unhappiness and you know
honestly you could probably scientific
studies and figure out
you know what the cause of that is i i
think freedom contributes to happiness
i think rights contribute to happiness
but then i think
social stress and anxiety contribute
more so
to unhappiness so don't i don't know if
it's that if
i wonder if you could look at social
pressures
and social media and find that affects
men and women
fairly equally in different ways like
you you look at young women in instagram
and you have these instagram models that
are all touched up with photoshop and
everything
and it's resulting in anxiety stress and
depression it's social issues that are
causing it
maybe you could argue that if you took
away someone's freedom and they didn't
have access to these platforms
then they wouldn't be unhappy with them
but i actually i don't i don't
think that makes sense i think it's just
like you know burning down the house
because you had a you know a plumbing
problem in the kitchen
you know what i mean i think by all
means keep the house fix the plumbing
find out what the problem is i think the
problem is
with unhappiness in general be it males
or females is social media
it's creating this pressure to conform
to certain things
to say certain things and then you it
results in like we mentioned before with
people like you know keith olbermann
saying
insane things about taking vaccines away
from people in texas because you don't
like their opinions
it results in people advocating for
beating others and committing acts of
violence
because they're increasingly more and
more desperate to fit in
we talk a lot about how young women are
influenced by instagram
there there was like apparently cosmetic
surgery based on snapchat filters or
something like this because they want to
clean their yeah
yeah they want yeah really creepy stuff
young women who will
will post a photo on instagram and then
not get enough likes and get really
depressed and start freaking out it's
really negatively impacting these kids
but then how how is it affecting men
because i'm sure it absolutely does
as you were speaking i was thinking um
you know and i relate this to
relate this to myself especially
especially as a as i guess a former
actor i don't know anymore
but you know like i follow the rock for
instance and i mean i love
i mean i love the guy i'm a huge pro
wrestling fan or at least i was
back when it was good and they i think
in terms of men and again this might
this might lead into sexual dynamics and
you know and
and and where people perceive their
value to lie maybe within the sexual
marketplace maybe not but
if we're talking about uh you know women
using filters and and beautifying
themselves on these platforms and not
feeling beautiful enough
in comparison to other women what about
these other accounts with you see these
men who are out you know i'm starting a
business and i have this amount of money
i got
flashing lots of cash exactly i got this
car i got this house i got this and that
so i think a lot of guys are looking at
that and they're being like that's not
me i mean i guess i'm just a big i'm
just a freaking loser man i don't know
i don't got nothing and then you know
and then i got these all these women are
commenting
on on on these posts and so maybe you
know that's part of it
maybe that's contributing to uh to mail
um unhappiness as well the
the success uh status the status
comparison is what i'm getting guys not
having
not having kids guys not having
relationships staying home and playing
video games all day
you know not not advancing i think i i
look i don't want to
just kind of shift this and dump it all
into social media but i really do think
social media is a huge issue
is affecting both men and women it's
really nice the education is around it
too like you said it's not
the freedom that's destroying them it's
their misuse of it because like you have
the freedom to light your body on
fire but you know not to and if you knew
that
the it wasn't the filters that made you
beautiful that would help
some people you know look you got a
freedom not to eat a whole ice cream
cake from baskin robbins but some people
will do it you know what i mean and i
was also thinking like when i would post
uh a video on something of me being like
oh i feel like crap
you two tweets two retweets two likes
and then less people would want to
follow me i post a picture of me on a
boat with a bunch of beautiful women
everybody wants to be my friend take a
look at this what you were saying about
these guys
casey neistat are you familiar with
casey oh yeah yeah he's like one of the
he's like the godfather of vlogging on
youtube
look at his look at his biggest videos
with 50 million views what is it
i'm in a luxury first class 20 000
airplane ticket
you know mini hotel in a plane it's it's
a lot of his biggest stuff was
flaunting extreme wealth and status and
i'm not i'm not saying that disparaging
disparity in any way i'm not saying it
on purpose i'm saying
you know he did a a video vlog where he
was flying on a on a
emirates flight it's like a 20 000
ticket and they give you a room
and apparently there's like a shower in
it or something like it's really crazy
wow i don't know if that was his video
but his video was like he has this
little
little room he's in and it gets like 50
million views because people want to see
that status it's like
it's why we had shows like lifestyle the
rich and famous and cribs
so very much so as we've entered the
space where
you now control your own media outlet
everybody's a public figure
for some reason and by all means the
feminists can tell me
why this is happening women have started
to focus specifically around
beautification
getting likes for their appearance and
their bodies
maybe it's a maybe it's a bad thing and
they shouldn't do it by all means
feminists can tell me
you know comment below and say they
shouldn't i'm not asserting my opinion
i'm just saying it's happening well
there's also you know
it's the question of power and you know
and again i go back to
you know my job and it's kind of funny
there's a comedian named patrice o'neill
who unfortunately passed away many years
ago from complications of diabetes but
you know he talks about how
he said he said i wish i could just walk
around for one day as a beautiful woman
because he talks about how
you know they they could be the the
plainest person just to have nothing
going on for them but if they look good
they can walk
they can walk around as if they're
celebrities and so i and so i look at
and so
again i'm at this i'm at this job and i
see it every day there is so much
and and it's strange i mean the same
thing i i try to watch my words because
i know that i will also get heat from
from gender activists and feminists
but to deny the power the raw power of a
of a beautiful woman
and the effect that it has on a man i
mean and even other women say like oh
she's so pretty you know
what do you do it's there is something
about that i don't even know if i can
put it into words or articulate it but
it definitely has an effect you can be
you know i mean i don't consider myself
somebody who
um i guess but by the nature of my
profession i'm just i'm used to being
around beautiful women so it's it's
demystified for me and and
in a way it's made me even more choosy
as far as who i choose to to date
because i'm like okay well i see all of
that but
you know what's what's inside what's
going on up here what's going on in here
but i i just even even i am sometimes
just like
powerful it's just feminine
and and and honestly it doesn't even
have to be she doesn't even have to be
super duper attractive she could just
have a certain way about her that's
what we kind of say you know and it can
it can completely disarm you and you
just you don't
you you don't know what i mean anthony
and cleopatra um um
uh uh the shakespeare play that's that's
sort of what it's about you see
this powerful man this general this
warrior and cleopatra is at home and she
has him wrapped around her finger
it's amazing do you have any like male
heroes or people you look up to like
you're a big fan of
um i have i have i have a few
do you ever meet them well a lot of them
are dead
but but one right right now that uh
that i like a lot is actually malcolm x
and which is which i think might
surprise a lot of people given my
viewpoints i mean i'm sure people who
follow him would call me and uncle tom
and all those other things but the thing
about it
in his autobiography in the epilogue or
the afterward to it
the the actor aussie davis who's no
longer with us unfortunately
he made the point that malcolm taught us
how to be a man when we were not allowed
to be men
and there's this clip that he of this um
this press conference that he gave after
his journey to mecca
and he um he was asked about
bringing the the case of of racial
discrimination and oppression of of of
black americans to the united nations
and he he said malcolm said i'm going to
paraphrase but he said you know i
i would not be a man if i did not you
know pursue this action and
he repeated that i just if i didn't
bring this case against the uh up to the
u.n i would not be a man and so for me
um you know even though the concept of
of maleness is
is consistently derided now um
i think there is a true power in in
being able to say
this is what i'm standing for this is
what i believe in and i'm willing to put
my life on the line to say this
and you know it's one of the things that
that inspires me to keep on running my
mouth right now it's like you know if
i don't say something about this then i
would not be a man whatever that means
or a human or or well but so well
before before you go too far okay yeah
yeah the reason i asked is
you know you're talking about how you
meet this woman and you get tongue-tied
and i started thinking about this a
while ago you know when they talk about
what
the average male or female finds
attractive it's like guys want
young beautiful women and there's a
variety of physical features that men
are attracted to
the okcupid cupid data showed that's
like 22 year old women almost
exclusively like
no matter how old the guy gets he always
goes for 22 year olds
and then i thought okay well they say
like what do they say about what makes
women
you know attracted to a man confidence
charisma and status
and i'm like so is there so you
mentioned that like a woman could have a
woman could have nothing going on for
her but just be beautiful
and then guys are like fawning all over
and all over yeah and i was like
so then what's the male equivalent of
this high
societal value and its status notoriety
and fame
and i'm like so then i wonder if there
are similarities between
you know guys who look at women and
they're like whoo and guys who look at a
celebrity or famous individual and yell
at them
not sexual advances obviously which
definitely gives guys a bit of that
privilege
because you know i'm sure a lot of it's
disgusting but when you're a guy walking
on the street and you have much people
like hollering at you and yelling at you
like yo yo can i get a picture of a big
fan
it's not identical but there's a
similarity there in this is what society
values in men this is what society
values in women
interestingly enough though women will
still get it worse when they're famous
and beautiful
because now everybody's yelling at you
because you're famous and they're
yelling at you because you're beautiful
so it's an interesting dynamic and the
reason i asked about male heroes is i
was wondering do you think you would get
tongue-tied if you came across
a male you know hero of yours who you
looked up to and was inspired by so
probably so
yeah i want that's not just just an idea
i was wondering about you there's a
actually in the film malcolm x i mean
denzel washington he was so unbelievable
in this role like
to this day when i see a picture of the
real malcolm i still i see both men
and there's a scene where in the film
where malcolm meets
elijah muhammad and denzel plays it so
beautifully he
he has his he has his head down and you
see tears start streaming down his face
this is a man who spent
his time in prison educating himself
learning how to speak this dude was a
former pimp
you know he goes into detail in his
autobiography yeah about how he learned
that the street slang you know
you know and so he so he he knows how to
talk to people
and yet in this at least as depicted in
this movie
he meets you know his his idol and he he
can't say anything he just starts he
just starts crying it's such it's
such a powerful beautiful moment and you
know and i
i will say i did get to meet harry
belafonte
and um that that is somebody that i said
you know i
i wonder if what i would say to him if i
ever met him
and i did a show off broadway where
he played the it was a
play called carmen jones and he did the
movie adaptation of it and he played a
character named joe which is what i
played off broadway and one night he
came to the show
and i i've been saying to myself what
would i say to him
if he showed up and i'm somebody who
is who is extraordinarily grateful to
the people that came before me which is
another reason why i step off i step
away from this woke stuff because i feel
like they keep erasing the heroes of the
past
but you know i got out i got out of the
theater walked around the corner and
there he is this 91 year old man
in this wheelchair eyes still bright
these bright blue eyes his great
cheekbones
and at a certain point you know i just
said thank you thank you for everything
that you have done
you were you're a warrior and you're a
trailblazer and
you know i just i just want to shake
your hand and you know like can i get a
hug and he just he got up
he's old 91 year old rickety self i mean
i get emotional thinking about it and
you know there's video of it and we just
and we hugged each other you know and so
that so that's one instance where you
know as i said
i just was like that i met a a
trailblazer and and the hero i was like
you know thank you so maybe
so maybe it's maybe say what not not
tongue type but but
i guess what i'm getting at is that
maybe it's it depends on who the guy is
and what situation that he's in his life
like i see other guys at the gym or
whatever and
you know they look good they're ripped
or whatever and i'm like wow good for
that guy
you know that guy looks amazing or i'll
see somebody who's like doing their
thing they're running a business they
make money
like wow good for that guy like you know
i could you know be there somewhere but
at the same time the flip side might be
man just me okay we're keeping the
family friendly so i can't uh
i can't say what i want to say but man
man look at this dude you flashing all
this man this big muscle man whatever
just you know we call them haters yeah
yeah yeah to be uh
i got a lot of them on twitter oh oh i
bet you do my friend you know i i
remember
i was working uh i worked working in
california once when i was doing
fundraising and i saw a dude pull up in
a very expensive car
you know like convertible and i'm just
thinking like
he looked really young like early 20s
and i'm like what is he doing like what
is he doing and i was like hey man
he's like yo what up i'm like what are
you doing like
you're making all this money you clearly
look like you're doing well it's a real
estate
and so it's like i saw that and i went
to a guy and i was like yo
i want to talk to you real quick because
i saw his power and his status
you know what i mean and i was like give
me some advice like he was a little bit
older than me
and i was like what is this how do you
afford this what do you do for a living
what's the
what's the key how did you get started
tell me tell me those secrets you know
what i mean that's like that's the plot
of uh
of the pursuit of happiness remember
that uh that will smith movie
where he is that makes it a true story
wasn't it yeah yeah but he sees a guy
and
driving a nice car and he's like you
know what do you do well i'm a stock
broker he's like well yeah i want to
learn how to do that how do i learn how
to
do that you know so i mean that's that's
the kind of thing you know i
i just i was speaking about this this
earlier uh to one of your colleagues
just about
this this creeping nihilism this lack of
this lack of aspiration
you know there's no
people
it's as if uh and especially with the
response to to covet people just content
with sitting in
and just shutting themselves in all day
and and never striving for anything
and in wanting to strive for something
that makes you greedy it makes you
selfish
you're not you're only thinking of
yourself but you know
how if you're constantly denigrating
people who want to build something or to
achieve something yeah they might maybe
they are selfish
but if that drives them to create you
know if that drives an elon musk to you
know to
launch rockets into space you know what
i mean then what's what's what's the
deal what's the problem with that why
can't we aspire to be like these people
um instead of tearing them down it seems
like there's a huge huge
cultural movement where it's like any
striving for any kind of achievement or
whatever is
is is looked down upon crabs in a barrel
man
crabs like like resentment like if
you're not
if someone's not striving and they see
someone that is there might be this
resentment maybe it's good do you know
the fries crabs in a barrel crabs in a
bucket
they snap at each other because they all
went out at the same time so when one is
climbing out the other one grabs trying
to pull itself up
they only knew if they worked together
they could all get out
the bottom guy would climb up their
backs first pull them off one at a time
except the guy at the top would have to
hang there and carry the weight of all
the other crabs
some we need one of those crabs to like
and introduce crab communism so they
understand the power of the collective
you know
like get a bunch of crabs to cling onto
the barrel in a circle and then a bunch
of crabs
so you have like a funnel of crabs and
that way i'll write off distribute the
weight
let's work together decentralize the
weight
it's the age-old mathematical problem
we've now solved it the crabs in a
barrel mathematical equation
simple there it is and all the crabs
that disagree kill them
and then we eat them there we go perfect
everyone wins in this scenario
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already go to timcast.com become
a member because we got
exclusive members only segments that
will be coming up of course
and uh smash that like button subscribe
the notification bell
uh it all really really helps so
seriously smash that like button
normally i like to start from the
beginning but i'm looking down at this
this one super chat
you know that's more more recent i have
to read it ashley underwood says clifton
i'm going to listen to whatever you got
to say just to hear you that voice wow
it's got the same something as james
earl jones is a good one congratulations
sir
thank you your training has paid off
beautiful yeah yeah is it is it you know
you you did
broadway acting you've done like vocal
you know what it's actually crazy
when people hear me speak and i'm
i'm i'm uh that rare breed of individual
i'm the straight guy who does musical
theater
and so and so when they hear me speak
like oh clearly you're going on the base
of the baritone line
but i have a range where i can sing not
crazy high but but much higher than you
might think
so i just have a really weird voice but
i will say
that the more the more comfortable that
i
that i that i get in myself that sounds
kind of weird but the more
comfortable that i am with myself and
the more that i mature the more that i
relax
into myself i mean i actually have to
monitor myself and how i speak because i
tend to speak very very very quickly
but it's it's actually sort of an
internal kind of a thing
uh actually where i um oh just do away
there's more
but but that's a lot more but uh but
just you know it it's
it's owning it's owning more of my male
is that that's really how i feel
masculinity that's how that's how i feel
about it and um for the longest time
you know i i was so focused on appeasing
other people
and pleasing other people and part of
that was speaking in a tone of voice
where
you know i'm trying to be friendly and
you know and it goes up here
but that's not where my natural voice is
when i'm when i'm more relaxed
this is where this is where i tend to
live i just get really excited
really really easily but so and part of
it is training you know you
everyone can benefit i think from you
know learning breath techniques and
learning where to speak from learning
where their resonators all are
um and it actually if i can you know
kind of go off for like a couple of
minutes
you know as an actor it's kind of fun
because then you learn where your
different resonators are where you can
place things so you can
so if i'm going down here i'm playing
someone who is from a
uh in africa for instance i can i can
make
zamunda because that movie just came out
i know i i'm not hearing great things
about it unfortunately
but or i can come up here and play a
completely different character and
resonate more of
of here you know or man i can come back
here and be just real chill bro you know
what i'm saying you did a jordan
peterson earlier that i was like oh wow
yeah it's it's seriously not good it's
not good
that's great these radical marx
yeah now see now i'm on the spot it's
it's it's a
it's it's not not quite as good as it
was but um yeah no it was really good
before the show because you were just
gonna wing it as a joke yeah i know
i was like whoa that one hit the you
know yeah well i
i i'll work on that and what was your
history like um
from like young young adulthood to
professional career how did you traverse
that my life makes no sense my friend
i you know i was uh my mom was in the
army i'm a military brat so maybe you
know every three to four years my life
was uprooted i was born in heidelberg
germany
uh maybe that's why today you know i i
just i i guess i like people i i'm not
you know i had friends who were turkish
and greek and dutch and all kinds of
things and
and uh but there was nobody in my family
who had any sort of artistic or at least
expressed artistic inclinations and
you know i was going to be an
illustrator that was my thing i dabbled
in music and like in poetry and prose
and stuff like that and then
at a certain point um you know i
basically left
uh i was in his french class for three
years i dropped i i didn't drop out but
i left to chase a girl basically into a
drama class and i just found out was
good at it and i got a lot of
encouragement and
uh in-state tuition was way way cheaper
to go to theater school and get a
useless
bachelor's degree in theater um and i
just sort of started
started going going from there you know
i never would have
i never really would have chosen to be
an actor you know it's going to sound a
little
pretentious and cliche but it kind of
chose me i just have sort of rolled with
it took me a long time to be comfortable
with it
and um you know so i i don't know the
answer to that i'm just i'm just kind of
a weirdo who
you know liked art and games and
wrestling and video games and comics and
then now i'm
chased a girl into theater school man
well let me let me read some more of
these super chats
so i jumped to the beginning i'm
thinking this one super chat i'm reading
is like just a funny one in the middle
it's usually so i go to the beginning of
the super chats and um
errant thought says good lord you should
do voice-over work pure honey
m sheba says i'm not gay but that voice
is sexy
you might be a little gay
all right all right uh straight alien
says the culture is better at hungry
jacks referencing burger king
all right let's see patty says i've
heard you and others refer to the third
degree charges manslaughter but the
minnesota definition is different and
requires
malice and disregard for life dude has
no chance at a fair trial anywhere
though
well they're trying to so his second
degree murder and manslaughter i believe
in the second degree for show then
and they're trying to add third degree
murder this is what i'm wondering how is
he going to get a fair trial
how can there be a jury that hasn't
heard of this isn't predisposed
that's a good question i have no idea i
have no idea
butters oregano says love when guests
have a great voice and excellent
enunciation
side note gme to the moon gamestop hit
like 200 bucks oh why are you serious
wow jeez man people are becoming
millionaires overnight from memes on the
stock
i kind of love it yeah especially
considering i mean it's gamestop which
people don't really like gamestop all
that much but but so
there is a part of me that's glad that
it's achieved some kind of relevance
again there you go yeah
shooter csw says look into the history
of international women's day it's
literally a communist holiday
is that true i did not hear that here's
another one
just jenny says my god his voice is
beautiful how much money did we make
simply because of your voice
all of these people super chatting just
give me a cut man that's all i ask for
10
10 percent tyrannos cigna says hello all
clifton what roles did you play while
doing shakespeare
um my favorite was uh macduff and
and who's the hero of the play macbeth
he's the one that kills the titular
character
um mcduff is interesting because you
know
when you're interpreting these roles you
know you want to look at
why is this character in the play what
is his function in this story
and how is he different from macbeth
macbeth turns into this uh
evil tyrant and dictator sort of like
andrew cuomo and um
mcduff on the other hand you see these
scenes there's only one scene
unfortunately with with his wife and
his kid and he has you know and whereas
macbeth is talking
you know about power and and darkness
and everything
macduff has all this text where he's
talking about he's referencing god and
you know and he loves his family and one
of the central scenes in the play
is where he learns macbeth has had his
wife and children killed and it's such a
brilliant scene it's often cut because
it's usually played pretty badly but
macduff is a great one caliban is
another one from the tempest
one of shakespeare's later plays and
that was interesting i did that in
washington dc
and caliban is explicitly referred to as
a slave he is a slave so right away when
i was cast
i knew like oh man we're gonna have to
deal with a bunch of backlash
and um you know but even though there's
a lot of language
in the play where he's like you know
he's a moon calf he's a monster this and
that
i said you know i'm going to treat him
as a human being because if i treat him
as some kind of
you know and you and you'll see
productions of the tempest where some
terrible director
is like we're going to make caliban an
alien and put spikes on him
but it's but it's alienating for the
audience and they can't really visit you
know the humanity of this character who
i felt like this this is a
uh this is a human being who's being
treated this way
and and what the audience and what the
audience receive is like
receives is what this poor put upon
slave and they begin to to empathize
with him
um so you know i don't want to go on and
on that's a great one did you hear
the apparently there's going to be like
a reboot of superman and
i don't know exactly what it is but they
were talking about casting a black man
as as superman
and i don't i don't know if i like i've
heard a lot of people say there's a
couple arguments
one one of the arguments i've i've
actually agreed with is that i think
it's really dumb that they do
hand-me-down characters exactly it's a
it's hand-me-down
franchises it's you you can't create
anything original we're going to give
you this thing
now you know i have to be careful and
measure what i say jj abrams is um
is producing it and you know people
knock uh jj but i will say
he co-produced the broadway show that i
did i found him to be very smart and a
very hard worker and when i hurt my back
he actually sent me some cookies
with a nice note on the stationary like
yeah sorry about your back um and a cool
guy but
i mean i i agree you know it's one thing
if you're doing you know
an alternate earth's kind of a thing and
and maybe there is a story that could be
told about um
you know about someone coming from an
alien planet who you know
who is a minority and has to find some
way to connect with this
this race of people around him that that
could be interesting in terms of a
stupid in terms of a superman story but
if it's just it's going to be superman
right you know then that's that's a
different that's a different sort of
thing i was always i learned
anyone can play any role boy could play
a girl girl can play a boy colors
doesn't matter as long as it's good like
if they make the stupid
story about like oh i'm suffering
because of the color of my skin that's
not superman
man superman's a hero well here's the
thing so there's a practice called
colorblind or non-traditional casting
it's very prevalent in the theater and
also in the opera
and there's often this argument of
saying well why can't it work in reverse
there's a playwright named neil labute
who
wrote an article an op-ed in l.a times
back in 2007 where he said well why
can't why couldn't brad pitt and
angelina jolie
do a raisin in the sun and the reason
for that is
and why it often doesn't work in reverse
is that there are so many works by black
writers wherein
being black is a central part of the
given circumstances of the play so with
a raisin in the sun for instance
there's a scene where this uh this white
individual comes into this um
and people and for people who don't know
the story it's basically about a black
family in chicago in the 1950s
who comes into money and they want to
move to a nice neighborhood that's all
white
and so this uh this representative of
the neighborhood they want to move into
um comes in and offers to pay them money
not to move you know it's just it's
racism
blockbusting say um redlining um
no i i forget the specific it's been a
long time since i've read it but it's
basically like you know we
want you know everything to be friendly
and and people to be happy where they
are and we just
and so and and a good director will cast
an actor a white actor who's very
friendly and very you know inviting to
to do that
but the point is the play doesn't work
right if you have a white if you have
white people playing the younger family
it's the name of youngers but i i also
think you know
it is weird like superman is an alien
but he looks like
just like a regular english being a
white dude and so
like even with starfire who's another dc
character she's orange at least
yeah and so i i got to be honest
the idea of taking an existing character
who is already defined
and then just kind of handing handing it
down i think is disrespectful and i
think it's a cop-out
instead of writing something yeah right
right make new original heroes with
awesome stories
you could play superman that'd be
awesome but i'd rather play captain
america personally
but so so look i like miles morales
spider-man
it's an alternate earth version because
there's there is the spider verse
and i think you know into the spider
verse was an awesome movie i got no
problem with that
if they just rebooted spider-man and
we're like you know we're just gonna
now celebrate the diversity by casting
this character i'm like
for 50 years or however long we've had
these heroes longer like 70 years or
whatever when superman get written
there has been he's he's been a
representation for certain for for you
know
he's been a representation of a certain
individual i don't think you're actually
doing anything for diversity or social
justice by now saying okay now that
we're done with it after seven decades
we're gonna you know cast it in a
minority position or something we need a
new hero universe
like desperately not just making just
write stuff it's like yeah where where's
the originality just make a new story
not even that hard
well also my fear about that is um
i excuse me there is a
in in in the entertainment industry
there is a a constant denigration of the
audience
they feel like they're smarter than the
audience and you know but even if the
audience
you know whoever comes to see your show
even if they can't articulate
certain things that they don't like they
can feel it and
my fear is that if we keep doing things
like this
and then when people push back against
it they say like
thor is a great example thor is a
character that i never thought that i
would enjoy that much but when i read
the comments i was like you know he's
he's a wonderful character
and um but when they cast but when they
said we're going to make uh
thor a woman and they said you know well
thor is just a title no it's not
right you know he's the son of odin and
he's the king of asgard you know and
if if you keep just and but if you no
matter how there was a great post on
reddit that said
you know it no matter how much you break
it down like no thor is not a title thor
is this person and you know but you
they'll still call you a misogynist or
whatever and so so if you say like yeah
i'm not really feeling a black superman
they're going to call you a racist and
so people i think
i'm afraid that when someone like me
comes along they're going to say i'm not
going to see that
it's just some black guy you know i'm
just i'm tired of seeing all these black
people
what are they there for this is
interesting you meant you mentioned uh
that one play about the black couple and
the white guy what was it called
raisin in the sun right right you said
the play doesn't work because literally
about a black family
and you know this thing was happening
and i feel there's a similar similar
argument to
thor right thor is literally the son of
odin he's an
uh what is he he's a norse god nor's god
so it's like to change those characters
about him and then take his name
also creates a really weird kind of
story break
and that this it's literally about this
god who is son of odin based on this
certain mythology
some characters it probably doesn't
matter when you do colorblind casting
it's you suspend your disbelief so a
woman will be playing the male role but
it will be a man character in the play
just played by a woman's the audience to
suspends their disbelief
accepts that it's a man doesn't matter
who's playing the role but when it comes
to skin color
that could be viscerally confusing and
when they change
a woman now and not a woman playing a
male role that can make it the story has
changed no i think
like what you were saying is you know if
if this if the element of the story is
the character is
you know of this race or this background
changing that just changes the story
yeah it would be like really weird if
like brad and angelina
were being racially discriminated
against as like a wealthy white
hollywood couple you know what i mean
like you know and actually my alma mater
my grad school
they did a production that caused a lot
of controversy where you had you know
these white student actors who are
playing these black characters and it's
just like wow
it just it doesn't work the play does
not make any sense at all but as a
statement
the play being the art itself as opposed
to the
actual performance i think is an
interesting point to be made about why
it doesn't work you know what i mean
yeah i guess yeah like because i need
people you show people and be like it's
kind of weird right
but you know but you know well that's a
whole other discussion about like how
how is it benefit i mean i guess it
could benefit if you're a student actor
and you are exploring you know maybe
cultures unfamiliar to yourself
then there's merit in that just but on a
professional level
no no one's going to go no one's going
to go see that show
all right let's read some more super
chats maddie says my dad is algerian
my cousins going to school here were
confused by forms because they weren't
black
but didn't view themselves as white
maybe we should start trolling and put
african-american because technically we
are from africa
do you hear about the kid there was a
scholarship for
african-americans and a white a white
blonde hair blue-eyed kid showed up
and when they were like what are you
doing here
he says it's for african-americans right
and they're like yes and he was like
i'm from south africa and now i'm an
american and they're like get out
but like for somebody who's not from
here they're like oh hey i'm from africa
and i'm an american
you know what i mean they don't realize
it was a racial thing i think he did it
as a troll though to be completely
honest yeah but i mean i've actually
worked with with
uh with like white people from from
south africa and it's and it's the same
that's why i don't use the term
african-american
it's just you know it's just it's too
broad and it doesn't really bring it
what are you reading right now written
britain you gotta read this super chat i
don't wanna interrupt you though
no i'm gonna figure it out i'm done i'm
done let's hear it matthew hammond says
would clifton go on zooby's show
it would be two amazing voices that
could read a phone book and be engaging
you know what man no but i really i
really like zubi a lot um i i've
we follow each other on twitter and um
you know he just seems like a decent
a decent guy and i see all the hate that
he gets on twitter i'm like dude
what do you do yes there's just so many
weather like this voice
clifton's voice oh jesus wait till the
radio show comes i'm going to talk like
this for the for the rest of the podcast
um that's what i'll do there we go
i'll just work like this and everyone
can simply send your super chats to tim
cast irl
that's the voice they were hoping for
when they donated that soothing
high-pitched screeching wine
doesn't it make you just want to take a
nap
curl up with your with your honey at
home and just
got me all right let's see hartford
house says frederick douglass birth
frederick douglass birth and death month
is february black history month
was that was that why they did it oh you
know i'm not sure about the order
my my complaint is it's really more
superficial but it's just it's just so
freaking cold bro like
you know just yeah just put it in a warm
up black people do not like cold weather
we just don't it's the shortest coldest
month we don't like cold weather i just
put it in june put it in june this is
the shortest month too
yeah you only get 28 days 29 every four
years so you know be happy with that
so acme product says the
collectivization of the farms in the uss
ussr led to rapid food shortages stalin
decided to steal ukrainian grain to feed
the cities of russia and starve out the
ukrainian nationalist movement
it's estimated three to five million
died i got the name of that british
journalist gareth
jones is that right no he was a welsh
journalist it was a different guy oh and
that was
so it's so disrespectful to him but
malcolm muggeridge
oh yeah yeah i think that's i think
that's what his name is that's right i'm
familiar with this name andrew turek
says hey tim thanks for another great
show would you ever consider having
colleen noir
on the show i think he's one of the best
two-way advocates on youtube and i'd
love to hear you all talk i would love
to have colleen on the show and
it's just it covet has made things very
very difficult for a lot of people and
so
we probably have a list of like 50
amazing people who are like dude we'd
love to come on
and we can't travel a lot of them are in
canada basically like every canadian
guest
except for those who have like somehow
made it out of canada before the
lockdown
so they're all like we're trapped here
um we'd love to come on the show when
they release us
wow wow it's canada's brutal man man
i can't famous quote psychia dargan says
history doesn't repeat itself but it
often rhymes mark twain
yeah yeah i like that quote we have a
second someone says i said i second
christina says i second the suggestion
to have colleen noir on the show that
would be awesome
i'd love to have him jb says would you
be ever willing
be willing to bring a nobody onto your
show from middle america to get out of
our perspective that's me yes just
kidding
what we were uh planning we talked about
a lot we were like we want to do a
regular
joe's kind of thing where we have like a
regular you know union member or
something we can be like i'm an idiot we
should get our dads on and talk about
firemen
well so the the challenge though is um
covid traveling and i think maybe like
the original idea was we're going to
travel around before like the original
idea for this channel
was to travel around the country and do
like setting up tables in random towns
and talking to regular people
so like in real life and then covet
happened and we couldn't travel
so maybe there's something still there
with doing that once things get better
so we actually are building a mobile
tour set up and the plan right now is
very preliminary
but we're going to travel to a couple
different cities spend a week in a city
and then do a friday night
live venue podcast that's cool where the
super chats are the audience
and the super chats like we'll do both
that's the plan which means a lot of
work has to be done
and depending on what the lockdowns are
like in various cities but i think for
the most part like we stay in like texas
and florida and stuff
we'd be totally fine also you know just
quickly one of the uh the things that i
love about the modern era you know in
platforms like youtube is that
i mean this idea of the like the
ordinary person or the common man or
woman i feel like is sort of
going by the wayside because everyone is
passionate about something
and i use this example all the time but
there's a guy on youtube who like trains
dogs and minks to catch rats and that's
like his thing
and he has millions and millions of
views on these videos and i'm thinking
to myself you know
or or you think about how the mo some of
the most astute political commentary
in 2016 was coming from an ex-satanist
who's sitting in his bathrobe
in his room in vermont and so it's right
so this idea
of of the ordinary person now i feel
like you know is sort of going out of
the window because there's something
extraordinary i think in
in a lot of people you know it's just
you just have to find whatever that
thing is that they like and i love that
i have access to that now i can like i
can watch these people and say oh yeah
and learn from them and just and grow
in a weird way deccan says tim
quote people have their own world views
based on where they live
also tim quote conservative parts of the
south very racist
you don't live in the south and don't
know our ways you out your outside
perspective well uh if i didn't say this
properly
what i believe i said was i have been to
conservative
parts of the south that are very racist
i have i have spent time there i have
lived there
i did not say all of the south was
racist i did not say that every
conservative is racist
there are places i've been to in big
cities where they believe a whole bunch
of far-left crazy stuff
and i think the world represents their
views and i have been to places
in parts of the south that are very very
racist and to be fair
i don't these people don't think the
cities represent their views
they just have their own world view
based on where they live but doesn't
mean every single southern state or
whatever is racist or every person is
mr kirk says hello big fan of original
trek
and and there were many interracial
kisses on the show
outside trek before the supposed first
interracial kiss
eg kisses between white men and asian
women on adventures in paradise and i
spy
interesting did not know that well but
asians uh
they're not considered a minority
anymore if i'm not mistaken oh no i'm
double white
you're white squared white square
exactly
you know what man dude i've heard some
of the most insane racist stuff about
these people
dude it's so i was told by a guy at uw
in seattle
that white supremacists love asians and
want to make hapa children be just like
how germany and japan was outlined in
world war ii
and i'm just like that is the stupidest
thing i have ever heard where you mashed
this like random idea from history you
know nothing about the war
and like the interactions between any of
these countries right
well you know what but i my so my
ex-girlfriend was japanese-american
and her and i have another friend of
mine who was also asian
they both said about themselves that
this was unprompted but they said you
know
i just always saw myself as white and i
was like that's really
that's really fascinating to me because
like full japanese
yeah well like i mean she was
americanized but you know but uh
but i was i was like wow i don't really
have that option how does that work for
you
you know what i mean so i don't so maybe
i don't know how much of that
maybe she might should grow up in like a
white neighborhood maybe and she just
found herself as part of an american
culture and associated that as whiteness
or something
i don't know man she's she's a
california girl and i mean she she has a
huge huge
um family that she seems very in touch
with with her culture so i don't know
what
where that ideology came from i i didn't
you know i actually got a lot of flack
from the alt-right
they said tim poole has no identity and
doesn't understand identitarianism
because
you know being mixed race he can't truly
understand what it means to have like a
cultural history or something like that
and i'm like i do i have two different
ones i don't know
like just like you're like someone could
be french
and swedish well then you have french
history and swedish history
but growing up i guess you know i grew
up i grew up in an area where
it was like very fairly diverse that was
it you know there are people of
different backgrounds
so there was no identifying as white
there was no like thinking you were
white it was literally
just like we're i don't know we didn't
have an identity he's like you know one
kid was italian
one kid was a polish immigrant one kid
was asian one kid was mexican one kid
was black and we were just like we're
americans i guess
we're skater kids like we it didn't
occur to us
and that really breaks my heart when i
see what what the modern identitarian
left does
because i'm like wow i really had that
like perfect mick
kid you know diverse childhood of all
these different backgrounds and cultures
and languages
and we all got along and had fun and
we're just kids growing up
nobody cared you know you would go over
to your buddy's house you'd play
nintendo or whatever for forever then
you get bored and you go outside and you
play some more and just nobody
nobody cared about it where's your
character where'd you grow up uh germany
virginia belgium and virginia so i spent
a lot of a lot of uh formative years in
virginia you know on
on military bases and you just hung you
know or or you know i'm in i'm in
belgium
you know from from ages uh from age
eight to twelve and like i said before i
mean i had friends from from holland i
had friends who were french who were
flemish
turkish greece greek all kinds of stuff
and you just no one ever cared about it
no one ever cares
it's a lot of fun julie simone she's got
some some fire for you
okay this likely won't get read given it
was ignored during the show but clifton
you completely stereotyped sexual
orientation in musical theater
are black stereotypes fair game then too
i mean
it was a joke obviously what i was
saying you know i mean the the
the straight man to musical theater i
mean but we are a very rare breed
and it's and i will say it's ironic
because i do run into people often who
say um
who said you know we we need more uh
masculine men in theater
and um but they're not writing roles for
for those kinds of people so
but you know there there's there's not
one theater person
who would not laugh at what i said
because they because they understand it
and it's um i mean you know the the
every musical i've done i've shared
dressing rooms with you know where i'm
the only straight guy in there and you
know no one really cares
so think about this interesting i'm also
a musical theater you know theater major
oh yeah were you in greece the musical i
played vince fontaine no i wasn't in
greece but i did buy by birdie was my
first movie oh great musical i
i can completely empathize and
sympathize with what you're talking
about yeah and
in a weird way it's kind of it's it's
kind of alienating because i'm
alienating because i'm like well i don't
really feel like i belong but then i'm
like i can't say anything because then
what are they
i feel like they're going to say back to
me well well well welcome to the club
buddy so i'm like all right cool
well think about it right this is a joke
that you
you're saying the people you know and
the communities you've been in would
laugh
because it's a joke that resonates with
you as people who are in musical theater
someone who actually does music
yeah people who are outside that would
get mad not everybody but there there
are people who are outside that so be
like you can't say that
that's offensive and it's like you don't
understand the joke because you're not a
part of the community where
right yeah would find it funny i don't
know it was like the least offensive
community
i'd ever been in the theater i don't
know about you what do you mean
when i was in it it was people were so
accepting of who we were it wasn't
really
well you know gender sex or anything
it's such it's such a weird weird um
thing because it's an industry where you
know
within within two weeks of meeting
complete strangers you're like making
out with them yeah getting underdressed
backstage yeah
yeah you're doing all kinds of things
where you're you know you should where
you're breaking down these mirrors and
even as a young kid i didn't
i didn't quite know what i wanted to do
but i also knew that i wouldn't belong
in an office anywhere and
you know and i'm just i'm kind of a
weirdo and i'm just like here's
here's a profession with a bunch of
other other weirdos and we can all just
be weird together
and enjoy ourselves highly recommend if
you're gonna go to college to go to
college for
an art degree at least for me i i'm
still in debt from it i don't care it
was the most
socializing um incredible experience i
met so many cool people
like i'm i never you don't need the
degree but the it's the experience
for me did you you went to college for
it too and then i went to grad school as
well
for theater yeah for for acting yes i
want to refa
uh mfa it's in my twitter bio i list my
credentials because everyone's doing
that now there you go
all right we got it we got a couple more
this is interesting uh d montoya says
calvin ellis was an alternate universe
superman who was black
and ra z razzaphone
says valzad is the name of the black
superman from earth 2.
the character was great not because he
was black but because valzad
was well written well there you go and
then
greg says how do you feel about a black
female being cast as anne boleyn
considering it's a historical white
person
it's just it's it's needlessly
inflammatory it's anti-historical
um again i mean i haven't seen this
project i know what this person is
referring to
but it's one of those things where i
just i don't feel like it really
accomplishes anything i don't
i don't know what they're aiming at i
mean it's one thing if you have a show
like
like hamilton which i think a lot of
conservative people don't really get
it's like well
why are all these black people playing
george washington and hamilton and
jefferson and all these people
but for me it's it's a wonderful
theatrical device where
they're telling a story in via hip-hop
that's really
that's really important and it's just
it's i think it's fun for most audiences
to come see it because you're telling a
a
a history although many historians have
had problems with
issues with the script but um
i feel like that's such a a different
kind of theatrical event versus
if you're trying to produce something
that's that's got a historical various
similitude then that's not the right way
to go about it and it just seems like
it is signaling for
this particular time and what and i know
you've got to but but
what and what i also i'm upset about is
that you know when you have these actors
who are just trying to build careers
they're just trying to do something that
they love that they enjoy
and they're thrust into these um into
these roles
um you know they don't deserve the sort
of heat that they get the criticism that
they get because actors don't give
themselves these jobs generally speaking
i you know i want to i want to clarify a
lot of what we're talking about earlier
that because i'm i'm thinking a lot
about this if if
i don't really care all that much about
uh superman being
having a black eye play superman i
honestly don't really care that much so
long as the character is written as
superman
character and it and it follows this you
know like storyline that you know stays
true to the character
i don't really think it matters who the
actor is and i think the issue with
hand-me-down characters is more so
when like in the comics they made thor a
woman it's like couldn't you just make
like
you know valkyrie or something like make
a new hero
for women that is more representative
instead of just being like oh yeah i
don't know
instead of making strong original
characters like the big three in the
marvel universe you can just have the
ones we're done with it's been a couple
decades and the sales are down
congratulations we just
it'll it'll there you go it's like we'll
just make a new cool character
but real quick too there already are a
ton of really amazing female characters
across the superhero universes that
already exist
and uh superheroes who are black or
asian
and i just like i'll put it this way i
want to separate these ideas when it
comes to acting
i honestly don't care if anne boleyn is
being played by a black woman
i really really don't it's a it's a
fictionalized theatrical
version of it and i honestly just don't
care she's got to be good
make the best actor do the best actor
that's the point well
if but if they're striving for
historical accuracy then it does not
work
if they're trying to do do something
make you cry
well i don't know about that just if if
they're if
what they're setting out to do is is
has nothing to do with historical
accuracy then that's a different thing
and then maybe i can entertain that but
part of the problem i hear is like you
know
going off of what you're saying i feel
like that would be fine
if we were not in the times that we're
living in right now and we didn't have
generations of this culturally ingrained
idea of of racism and you know
i feel like there's no way to do it now
to to race swap
a character like that without it seeming
as though you're trying to make some
kind of a statement and i think when
people see that they're going to be
turned off by that kind of a thing you
know
if uh we have a lot of people pointing
uh
i'm gonna read the super chat because a
lot of people saying the same thing um
ryan pennington says
first super chat thank you for
everything the problem with this new
superman is that it's being written by
tana hessie coates yes so
i'm not super familiar with with the
work of tatahsi
tanahisi coates is um is
what many on the i guess in the
anti-woken
and the right leaning crowd would call a
race hustler
um his his views um
are very and again i used to share these
kinds of views his views are very
typical of
of the left regarding race about the you
know america being oppressive america
being very racist and he actually
wrote a run on captain america and black
panther i don't know how the sales are
doing of those but
for me when it was announced that he was
writing captain america i'm saying well
how can you have this person
who who seems to hate everything
or at least misunderstand everything
america stands for
writing steve rogers it doesn't work so
when you have uh so when you have coates
writing a character that stands for
truth justice in the american way
um you know maybe truth maybe justice he
might have views on that but the
american way i'd like i don't
i don't know if if i think the issue is
people might
feel like he doesn't quite have the the
i the idealism or the sort of patriotic
attitude that would that might
help that would make a superman story
more authentic that said
i'm not super familiar with with the
with the superman ethos and
you know and the character people might
have people might have other views on
that but
but you know for for me and i think for
a lot of people it's the idea of like
this
this seems like someone whose ideology
um doesn't really match up with
with right with the character he's been
given to
right one of one of the movies i bring
up periodically is a spiral i think it
was called
and uh i don't know if you heard me talk
about her if you've seen the movie
it's a horror movie from shutter which
is like a subscription horror movie
service
and the issue i had with it is you know
the movie starts
and it is an interracial gay couple who
has a daughter
and i'm like that it's it like i'm
unfazed by this i'm like okay cool like
let's let's watch i'm interested i see a
loving family with a kid and i think
that's fine you know it doesn't really
like it doesn't stand out all that much
the problem arises
when the story's plot is literally
driven by the fact
that they're an interracial gay couple
instead of just having a horror story
where a demon comes to possess the
daughter and the family's fighting to
protect her
and i can just generally relate to that
it becomes very specifically about
a bunch of immortal white people who
want to kill marginalized people
and i'm like now you're beating me over
the head with it
and i'm like as kind of like a weird
very angsty and angry and so i think the
issue is
we have all these movies where
supposedly um
or actually you know coming off of what
you were saying about how if
if if uh if the story is like a black
family without in the
housing issue it makes sense that the
family is black it doesn't work if
they're white
you have this movie where it doesn't
doesn't have to matter that it's an
interracial gay couple with a kid
you have a bunch of movies where it's a
white family and there are ghosts and it
doesn't matter if it was a white family
or a black family the horror story works
regardless of the race and ethnicity of
the character
why can't we just have these things you
know what i mean like why can't they
make a movie where we have an
interracial gay couple with a daughter
but it's just like a regular horror
movie that's well written
that that you know scares you without
jump scares i hate jump scares
like just tell a good story like have
you ever seen the others
one of the best like horror like nicole
kidman really really great
writing clever movie and you know you
could make these movies with diverse
casts
and characters and all that stuff and it
would still be a great movie instead
what they do is they write social
justice like letters to social justice
for you
and then they call it a horror movie and
you know
hey if you have if you had a black
horror movie it'll be a really short
horror movie because
everyone knows that black people die
first he'll be like the opening credits
boom click ending crawl but uh seriously
though but what you're saying is
one thing that i've been beating on in
public is is that this idea of
you know there is a universal human
experience and you can have you know a
gay interracial couple
but as long as it's rooted in like if
it's a horror movie we want to see what
they do to survive
and get out alive how do they use their
wits their strength
how do they survive this um this deal or
oh they don't want it the evil the the
evil
white immortal people they're a spoiler
alert but i've spoiled the movie already
before
basically what they say they explain is
that every 10 years they trick
marginalized people into coming into the
town
so that they can sacrifice them for
immortality oh come on man it's just
it's just like very very
over the top like i get it because
here's my thing
and and i say like i made a tweet about
like you know i never got into acting to
be an activist and there are too many
people now i feel like who are
saying that we want to send a message we
want to
you know we want to inject our activism
into the story
where it would probably be more
effective if you focused more on
storycraft
and telling a good story you know i two
examples that i use often
movies that came out around the same
time indie films one was called pariah
which is a coming of age story about a
young
black lesbian in new york city the other
was called gun hill road which is a
coming-of-age story
about a uh a young like a 16-year-old
latino
male who is transitioning into female
and
you know you see all these sort of
awkward interactions first love first
kisses
um uh you know the the how it affects
the family and it's like okay like we
we see that now we we i can relate to
that you know
i'm looking at a slice of life that i
don't really understand or that i don't
necessarily identify with but as a human
being i'm sitting there i'm saying like
oh yeah the familial strife
the awkwardness of first love trying to
find navigate sex and dating
which you know it's going to have even
more challenges you know and we want to
we want to see conflict in our drama
that's
that's one of the core tenets of drama
you know how does this character deal
with these new challenges that they're
invited into their
they're invited and see you know i speak
quickly now that they're inviting into
their lives like that's what i want to
see i want to see the human struggle how
do they overcome adversity i don't want
to be preached at and
given some sort of message i don't need
to be improved when i go to the movies i
just i want to
experience something there's there's
watching like the grudge
there's no racist narrative when the
creature climbs out of the black
shadows of the wall and it's like a
demon going
yeah right exactly that's so creepy it's
just a creepy movie you know yeah
well let's let's do one more super chat
and then we'll jump over to the
members only stuff jennifer reems says
clifton has the coolest voice ever
he has my vote to narrate the coming
civil war
there you go well thank you appreciate
that all right if you haven't already
smash that like button
go to timcast.com become a member
because we're going to have a
uh uh exclusive members only segment we
uh we we didn't get to a lot of the
stories this often happens
look we got all these stories and then
we'll just get into the conversation it
happens but over at timecast.com we will
have another one coming up in about an
hour or so
so go to tempgus.com become a member
like share subscribe if you really do
like this podcast and you're listening
on itunes or spotify
leave us those good five stars leave us
a great review it really really does
help
and share it with your friends the only
really real way podcasts grow is from
word of mouth
but uh clifton you want to mention
anything before we go uh sure you can
follow me on twitter at
cliftona duncan you can also find me on
instagram at clifton duncan online i
also have a youtube channel that's my
name clifton duncan that i'm growing
and um you know if if you're an artist
out there and you feel like
you are that you're being silenced and
that you're afraid just
you know reach out to me and you know
i'm connecting with all of these people
so so many of us are afraid but you know
i'm still figuring out what i'm doing in
this space that i keep getting drawn
into
i'm being urged to create a podcast and
do all kinds of things
so um just keep a look out for what i'm
up to and you know i'm just
i'm happy to to speak with with with you
all
and and to visit and stop by and i
appreciate it you give me a chance to
run my mouth a little bit love having
you here man that was awesome hey man i
just enjoyed it it's cool
so except all the creepers that were
like man his voice is just so
you know because no one was like man
he's so smart and what what he's an
insightful person they were like he just
makes me just
super professional yeah i know you're
vibrating all the objectifying people
out there you should be ashamed of
yourself
just keep giving them money though so
just just do that thank you
i love it thanks dude oh hey guys you
can follow me on eating crossland.net
and then you can check out all my
socials and
and dig it i love you all man thanks for
coming this has been really fun
very cool yeah great chat with uh
clifton here i had a wonderful evening
my socials i just do twitter and mines
and i am sour patch lids on both of
those platforms and then i'm also real
sour patch lids
on instagram and gap
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast my other youtube
channels are
youtube.comtimcastyoutube.comcastnews
this show is live monday through friday
at 8pm so we'll be back tomorrow of
course and it's also my birthday
tomorrow
oh snap we'll see what happens tomorrow
like for all i know i'll be like just
laying there be like you know that's my
birthday i'm not working but we'll see
we fully intend to have everything as as
per usual i'll just wait till the
weekend for the celebrations or whatever
but uh thanks for hanging out go to
timcast.com
because we will have a segment up in
about an hour and we will see you all
then bye guys
you